salut à tous et bienvenue pour ce
dernier épisode des boissons
sur la chaîne de Gauthier Geo spoil ça
rigole un peu parce qu'on est parfois du
tout ils sont en train de faire les tous
leurs postes il y a clotil qui est dans
un coin de la pièce là-bas
des priorités donc voilà donc si vous
suivez la chaîne du coup moi c'est pas
Gauthier au spoil moi c'est the Willow
et Gauthier Paul du coup il est juste
ici mais il est un temps de présenter
bonjour salut comment ça va sur le
portable ça va très bien
est-ce que tu peux te présenter
rapidement si on a deux trois là
on peut suivre Gauthier Delplace
Go spoil sur sur le web
donc je suis je suis quoi on s'en fout
j'ai une chaîne où je parle de géologie
d'environnement et de plein d'autres
sujets voilà une chaîne Youtube et une
chaîne twitch obviously si vous êtes
dessus ou apparemment fait du JdR
scientifique incroyable mais pas que
mais pas que mais on en parlera à la fin
de l'émission
il y a des commandes pour aller voir ses
autres réseaux du coup point
d'exclamation Gauthier pour la
réclamation j'ai au spoil pour
l'exclamation Fredo exactement puisque
je jouerai Fredo Frédéric petit dans le
chat et on vous balance des liens et si
jamais vous y arrivez pas à vous
demander un modo elle et voilà à l'aide
j'y arrive pas et voilà
quelqu'un qui vous dit il y a qui
d'autre il y a
oui Valentine j'avais le nom de ton
perso dans lequel j'avais dit Eglantine
non non
comment tu vas très bien très bien et
toi ça va tranquille est-ce que tu peux
te présenter aussi pour si on a deux
trois qui n'ont pas suivi au fond de la
salle là tout à fait bonjour je suis
Valentine alias science de comptoir sur
Youtube où je parle de caillou et ici je
suis églantine bidon et je suis donc SIO
de la startup Flappy qui fait de la
prospection minière et pétrolière
on a Clotilde qui est revenu de son coin
envoyer des des stages je ne sais pas de
la source d'énergie comment ça va ça va
oui bonsoir tout le monde donc moi je
suis que le teacher ici de la chaîne
passer sauvage c'est une chaîne où on
parle de sciences humaines et sociales
donc archéologie anthropologie histoire
voilà et puis ce soir j'incarnerai
Gloria coupros une archéologue perdue
dans le futur et qui essaye de retrouver
son chantier abandonné
exactement je vais découvrir un truc un
peu bizarre dans ton gentiment futur la
dernière fois tu te rappelles
l'archéologue
j'ai quand même dessiné un spermatozoïde
sur mon petit carnet
là dans la tête de Guillaume
je pense pas de problème
la petite secte souterraine
à un objet non j'ai cru qu'il allait
arriver quelque chose là voilà mais non
il est arrivé voilà
donc toi aussi tu as des commandes dans
le chat pour l'exclamation Clotilde
point d'exclamation Gloria point
d'exclamation passez sauvage voilà et le
dernier du coup Arnaud Arnaud de stupid
economics donc une chaîne de journaliste
économique où on parle de
sujets de sujets de société voilà ça
arrive ça arrive le sujet de société
de problématiques économiques j'ai des
choses de choses du genre donc voilà où
ça se passe très bien je bégaye
relativement peu importe je voilà je
prends mon temps
tout va bien
heureusement qu'on peut couper les
choses enfin le montage aide beaucoup
et ce soir j'incarne Alain Pierre Alain
Chicheportiche président de CCI qui
maintenant n'existe plus malheureusement
dans le futur et mon but est bien tout
simplement de développer l'économie
d'horizon et
de faire preuve d'humanisme ça a
toujours
mes commandes prendre un bon point
d'exclamation
Arnaud point d'exclamation Pierre Alain
Chicheportiche comme ça s'écrit et point
d'exclamation
stupide économics voilà exactement bien
joué voilà on remercie le CNC qui nous
aide à financer ce projet lequel des
savoirs qui nous prêtent le studio et
qui nous aide beaucoup un petit
remerciement de toute l'équipe à la fin
de l'émission vous si jamais vous avez
des questions sur des notions qu'on a
abordé dans l'épisode gardez les vous en
tête et à la fin on vous dira allez
maintenant la donnez-nous les questions
et à ce moment-là distribue dans le chat
twitch et on les reprendra et on en
discutera autour de la table tous
ensemble vous allez avoir des sondages
et des quiz dans le chat qui vont se
passer à certains moments donc
surveiller bien ce sera marqué sur
l'écran ou alors je surveiller le chat
concrètement
les sondages ça va vous permettre
d'influer sur ce qui se passe dans
l'aventure les quiz si vous avez juste
vous permettre de donner des bonus ou
des malus au prochain jet des joueurs
voilà du coup bah on est prêt pour
lancer ce dernier épisode des breath of
the spollium générique
[Musique]
notre groupe est arrivé au sein d'iris
en début de journée un village paisible
d'apparence mais qui le siège de
nombreux jeux de pouvoir après une
journée bien remplie dans laquelle ils
ont trouvé la recette de la synthèse de
spodium et affirmer leur désaccord avec
les Aigles rouges auprès du maire
ils ont été forcés de payer leurs dettes
envers Lara la baronne de la pègre
locale cette dernière leur avait proposé
de l'aider à retrouver une certaine
Mélissa qui lui devait beaucoup d'argent
en échange elle effacerait la dette
qu'il lui doit
après quelques recherches et sont
tombées sur Mélissa prisonnière d'une
secte qui a pris possession des ruines
séléniques sont donc décidé de libérer
elle et sa fille avant de la livrer à la
les voici donc au beau milieu du village
d'iris en début de soirée ça fait
rendez-vous avec un marchand qui vous
amènera à marignise demain et d'ici là
qu'est-ce que vous faites
bien ma foi
toute cette lutte contre les dérives
sectaires d'iris ma fatigue
j'ai pas compris mais moi aussi je suis
fatigué et du coup je suggère au groupe
souhaitez-vous chers compagnon compagnon
que nous allions à l'hôtel
tout à fait un RIB
eradom d'initiative partagée
non mais
très bien vous avez pu lancer il est un
peu tôt quand même
le biorythme ah bah oui non mais moi moi
je vais je vais pas aller me coucher
tout de suite d'accord tu veux faire
quelque chose
bah oui
plutôt je vais aller me balader au
marché
attends 2 secondes faut mieux que Nico
s'il vous plaît
de toi quand tu parles le jour dans la
merde merci excuse-moi
je voudrais je voudrais retourner au
marché ok ça marche je retourne au
marché parce qu'il y avait un petit
stand artisanat qui m'a bien plu et j'ai
pas eu le temps de tout regarder
c'est en train de remballer mais il y a
quand même encore quelques trucs un
petit jeu d'intelligent intelligence
d'accord attends je suis où elle est où
l'intelligence elle est là
et Ben et ben zéro et ben 6 non comment
on fait si tu comprends rien
oui mais là les dizaines c'est zéro ok
donc 6 sur 70 donc tu n'es pas du tout
obligé d'acheter quoi que ce soit oh
un petit peu quand même hein
je veux je promets
c'est du désir après mais quoi c'est
d'accord donc je suis pas obligé
d'acheter quelque chose en même temps je
crois que j'ai pas beaucoup de sous
j'ai une pile une machette qui m'a pas
bien servi
ette
[Rires]
il y avait le grand feu là je vais
retourner voir le non l'arc-en-ciel
c'est les lumières de la ruelle c'est ça
et il y a un feu au bout ok il y a le
grand feu de la place là OK et ben je
demande je sais pas je suis autour du
feu puis je croise une femme et je lui
demande comment on part d'iris
par la route
ouais mais par quel comment on nous
amène attends
attends
on y va demain
on s'est déjà prévu l'itinéraire est
déjà tracé
[Rires]
non mais en plus on n'est pas censé être
là donc elle est censé être parler avec
non mais faites la conversation comme si
on était pas là surtout
bah non mais en fait je discute pas
parce que je suis pas très sociable
il est maintenant minuit
[Rires]
je sais pas qu'est-ce que
bah très bien bah je sais pas je rentre
à l'hôtel du coup je vais me coucher
plus tard je sais pas
très bien bon vous passez une nuit bien
reposante si il vous manque un point de
vue vous pouvez en récupérer
moi j'ai jamais pris des risques donc
j'ai tous mes points de vie
on l'ajoute sécurité
le lendemain relativement tôt qui va
être vers 8h du matin et vous aviez
rendez-vous à 10h parfait à la sortie
est d'iris avec le marchand que vous
aviez rencontré la veille
mais du coup Gloria est-ce que tu
arrives à te réveiller à 8h du matin
je sais pas j'ai déjà fait ça dans je me
suis déjà parlé non mais je vais pas
louper le trajet par contre
[Rires]
c'est pas tout seul c'est bon
ok ça a lancé de quoi
rythme décalé tu crois ah oui pardon ok
à 86 tu dors grave les gars
donc on a l'habitude maintenant donc moi
je toque à la porte voilà nous on va au
petit déj on lui rappelle rien
vous savez comment ça se passe
maintenant on a l'habitude je suis
tellement pavé
donc je pense qu'on prend juste notre
pavé enfin nous on mange tranquille et
puis et puis on l'amène avec nous
je prends les jambes parce que je suis
sportif du coup hop je cale sur les
épaules et j'avance les gens doivent
parfait
une vieille femme qui est endormie sur
toi
non mais c'est la grand-mère
ok vous arrivez vous rencontrez
effectivement le marchand avec qui
vous avez donné rendez-vous
si on a payé n'est-ce pas monsieur
Chicheportiche qui est très habile en
vrai qu'on a déjà payé mais alors là
attendez comment c'est possible qu'on a
déjà payé alors que j'ai le souvenir
d'avoir vu ma main
tendue vers la vôtre
peut-être oui et de l'argent a été
échangé j'ai pas reçu d'argent mais si
vous êtes un roublard
et vous avez même dit je viendrai avec
vin je vous ai dit non gentiment
[Musique]
contre font les bons amis vous nous
amener à Marie-Lys
en voiture une bonne heure non mais
c'est bon alors voiture
vous aviez dit combien 20 c'est ça 30 30
l'inflation c'est terrible chez vous ça
me pardonne pas
25 et puis comme ça les bons contre les
bons amis
34 boum boum boum ok il accepte
à 25 parfait moi j'ai 10
[Rires]
vous avez combien vous et moi j'ai 3 ans
oui peut-être ça on peut
[Musique]
peut-être
tout ce qu'on a donc 13 + 10 plus de
machette
vous avez que ça
on a un splendide microscope
électronique à balayage jamais utilisé
qui vient on dirait du passé
ça vient du passé
avec -20 quand même parce que c'est
45 ça veut dire quoi
j'accepte ah non mais pour ce tarif là
par contre vous nous emmener là-bas et
vous nous attendez sur place et vous
nous ramener après à élixir il nous
offre le café avec un café aussi et un
blanc d'Inde
je veux bien vous faire
le trajet jusqu'à Elixia à 15 euros
si vous avez un nouveau besoin que je
vous transporte
un microscope pour aller à Marylis et
après il prendra 15 pour aller à alixia
par contre pas marchandable les 15
donc c'est bon ok mais on verra à Gaïa
ce qu'on fait mais si vous êtes pas là
moi je fais mon chemin
vous repartez quand ça dépend quand j'ai
écoulé mes stocks d'accord donc on
revient vous voir et si jamais on
repartez repartir ensemble ça marche là
on se serre la main
il est fou dans son coffre prenez-en
soin je lui file quelques lamas sans
plus ça sert toujours que c'est parce
que c'est mais non
super truc balayage mais il sait pas ce
que c'est que enfin moi non plus mais
la convaincu que c'est quelque chose qui
va aller chercher bien joué d'avoir
voulu ça
par contre on laisse des traces de notre
passage chaque fois que depuis le début
je pense que ils sont jamais content
[Musique]
ok
vous prenez la route vers un barilys
vous vous écartez du village vous vous
retrouvez vous connaissez un peu ça
maintenant vous êtes dans le véhicule
vous y voyez vraiment pas grand chose et
je le véhicule qui éclaire la route
devant vous le reste c'est noir noir et
au bout d'un moment vous vous mettre en
rentrant vous mettez en vente des bruits
et vous vous faites arrêter assez vite
finalement genre une dizaine de minutes
de trajet de d'iris vous faites arrêter
par un groupe d'hommes
qui arrête le véhicule
le marchand qui on va appeler comment
vous voulez qui s'appelle le marchandise
donc sablier baisse la fenêtre et il y a
un homme qui s'avance vers le véhicule
qui dit bonjour c'est pour la taxe
[Musique]
pas très serein mais ça va je regarde
monsieur Chicheportiche à l'énonciation
du mot taxe pour voir comment il réagit
plutôt bien d'accord
on verra bien moi je regarde monsieur
sablier
comment parce que c'est pas moi qui vais
la payer la taxe c'est lui qui va payer
qu'est-ce qu'il fait monsieur sablier
est-ce que on peut regarder à quoi
ressemble les gens qui demandent les
taxes
distinctif est-ce qu'ils ont un habit
quelque chose il me semble un peu aux
partisans de Lara dans leur façon de se
s'habiller qui vous avez chopé en ville
et il vous laisse passer
ils ont regardé dans le véhicule où ils
ont juste derrière dans le véhicule
pour avoir la protection de la
même en partant de
commercial
on est amis de Lara
on s'entend bien quoi il y a pas de
voilà il y a rien de plus c'est bizarre
regardez la route
je fais juste la conversation
très bien vous continuez de votre chemin
jusqu'à Marylise vous finissez par
arriver
au village en vous arrivez à Marylis
c'est un petit village qui est construit
sur le versant du Mont Nivelles donc à
l'opposé de ton site de fouille Gloria
si magnifique je peux me réveiller j'ai
envie de me réveiller
une heure de trajet en voiture tu as eu
le temps de finir ta vie
et le village il est entouré de
gigantesque champs et verger en tout
genre vraiment
[Musique]
et au milieu de tout cette vie paysanne
c'est pittoresque je cherche le mot
quand même
très bien éclairé
si on allait voir Hélène de Gaïa pour le
dire que Céline a envie de la rejoindre
donc vous arrivez à l'entrée de dammaris
vous vous rendez compte que le village
une fois que vous vous êtes un peu
approché il est plus petit kiridis il y
a beaucoup moins de monde dans les rues
parce que ce n'est pas un peu le c'est
pas le où on névralgique du commerce
donc forcément il y a juste les
habitants en fait
les bâtiments on touche une allure très
étrange un mix de vieilles bâtisse
amélioré avec de nouvelles technologies
liées au spodium énormément de verdure
était par terre de fleurs jonche les
rues et les murs des bâtiments ce qui
donne un look très accueillant de
manière générale les rues sont bordées
de commerce et d'ateliers d'artisanat ou
les habitants vendent les produits
qu'ils ont fabriqué eux-mêmes ça va vous
plaire un groupe de garde c'est que des
femmes qui vous arrêtent enfin qui
arrête le véhicule qui demande à laisser
passer et s'habiller vous dit bon bah
moi du coup je vous laisse là je vais
vendre mes marchandises et puis voilà je
vous fais descendre du véhicule lui
montrer un papier et il continue son
chemin ah oui quand même
pouvez nous lâcher après le
il est bizarre ce sablier
[Musique]
on avance vers le groupe de personnes OK
bonjour bonjour une belle journée
n'est-ce pas ça peut aller
moi ça va
il fait chaud
à Marylise tout ça voir comment ça se
passe
le tour
du tour du monde
[Musique]
vous avez un laissé passer pour rentrer
dans le village
allez c'est passé de quel ordre
des dirigeants
mais c'est du tourisme vous savez on
n'est pas là c'est sur la route on s'est
arrêté
c'est pas possible de faire du tourisme
ici vous pouvez visiter les champs si
vous le souhaitez mais si vous voulez
rentrer dans le village il vous faut un
laisser passer des dirigeants
à être à ce que vous ayez un rendez-vous
sauf si c'est une demande d'urgence bah
c'est urgent oui
parce que on a entendu parler du petit
fromage de chèvre de type roulé qui est
vraiment une spécialité d'amaryllis et
on avait très très envie urgemment de le
déguster celui cendré avec les Bresles
je me tourne vers mes camarades je leur
dis et sinon peut-être on va visiter le
chant on rencontre des paysans on essaye
de
rentrer comme ça quoi
voilà par exemple
sinon on peut aller voir Gaïa si on nous
laisse pas rentrer à Marie
Hélène Hélène voilà parfait
[Musique]
excusez-moi il faut passer par le
village pour aller à Gaillard
il faut forcément laisser passer une
autorisation spécifique des dirigeants
du coup est-ce que si vous voulez
demander une audience moi je peux vous
prendre un rendez-vous mais ça va
prendre quelques jours mais c'est pas
pratique
elles sont occupés
[Musique]
c'est urgent regardez-le pour Robert
à ce cette pauvette mais je sais pas
c'est bien pour ça que je suis là
j'aimerais aller voir
le vétérinaire ou quelqu'un quoi
puis je comprends bien mais vous allez
devoir forcément passer par les
gardiennes par les dirigeants mais très
bien mais que ça aille vite quoi faire
comprenez bon je vais voir ce que je
peux faire merci
elles sont bons enfin il y en a une qui
s'en va les autres vous empêchent de
passer quand même
et puis vous êtes mis sur le côté et
puis en attendant elle contrôle le reste
des personnes qui rentrent et qui
sortent de village au bout de un petit
moment sauf si vous voulez faire un truc
entre-temps
qu'est-ce qui rentre dans le village
des paysans des paysans
rien de particulier
il aurait pu nous prévenir
c'est que il voulait qu'on peut rentrer
parce que là du coup c'est vraiment pas
pratique
[Musique]
elles connaissent Lara
on peut peut-être tenter ça de dire en
fait on est en mission par les aigle
rouge
c'est la Pyrénées
[Musique]
ou alors est-ce qu'il y aurait pas des
inspecteurs qui pourraient inspecter à
Marie on est déjà arrivé en disant on
est des touristes donc
on va tenter le chien on va voir ce que
ça donne CHIEN Le chien je veux dire
le seul truc qu'on peut faire c'est
aller voir des paysans dans les champs
c'est vraiment la dernière idée mais
c'est la dernière
officieux ou alors sachez que je fais
très bien la morte auquel cas ça
pourrait être une urgence
[Musique]
et planer on creuse un tunnel des gens
ok au bout d'un moment elle finit par
revenir
elle vous dit
bon visiblement les dirigeants ont déjà
entendu parler de vous en tout cas mon
très bien décrites enfin très très bien
décrit donc vous êtes conviés tout de
suite et pour votre chien je vais pas
vous allez devoir attendre
un peu mieux mais je vais le surveiller
mais merci quand même c'était le voyage
c'est très émotif
mais merci de vous être renseigné c'est
gentil déshydratation
elle vous emmène à travers les rues de
dammaryllis en fait le village il est
construit en donc sur le versant de la
du Mont en fait le ça monte un petit peu
sur toute la ça
encore bien sûr je vais quand même
prendre le bras de sortie
utile et avec le sourire parce qu'on
n'est jamais aussi beau que quand on
fait du sport
c'est vrai c'est vrai Gloria prenez
beaucoup des leçons de vie comme ça on
serait pas qu'à 60 ans on puisse encore
apprendre à ce stage là mais si grâce à
vous merci
pour arriver tout en haut du village où
il y a un espèce d'hôtel de ville donc
la gardienne vous fait rentrer vous
amène dans une salle où il y a cinq
femmes qui vous accueillent
bonjour et soyez le bienvenus dans notre
village à Paris
on a déjà entendu parler
donc si j'ai enfin de ce qu'on a compris
vous faites partie des aigles rouges
[Musique]
vous n'aviez point là
exactement
rouge de votre point de vue à vous les
soldats d'horizon non mais nous on est
des colombes blanches c'est oui
[Musique]
on les a on les a rencontrés sur mais
c'est juste qu'on est dans une mission
un petit peu particulière qui est
qui verse vers le sauvetage de monde
donc on va partir du principe
c'est trop pour nos épaules mais oui
mais attends
c'est là c'était pas irrite
[Musique]
oui bonjour en fait il faut continuer
si vous voulez on aime beaucoup ce que
vous faites ici vous avez acheté aux
conditions et nous c'est vraiment ce
qu'on cherche à faire parce qu'en fait
on n'en peut plus
tard
du monde avant qui est ça est-ce qu'on
aimerait c'est pouvoir faciliter
l'adaptation de la société alors
attendez lundi trop mais
voilà c'est tout ce que je peux vous
dire botanique c'est une mission secrète
botanique m'a confié c'est une MSB
on m'a confié la mission spéciale
botanique de venir apprendre de vous de
vos pratiques ah c'est bien
pour pour divulguer vos secrets
professionnels mais je ne peux pas vous
en dire plus les Aigles rouges veulent
espionner que les Aigles rouges
le voyant vert je fais c'est rouge ça
c'est vert on est les crapaud vert donc
moi je fais le 27 sur 40 les crapaud
verts
je ne peux pas vous dévoiler cette
information d'accord vous connaissez pas
je ne souhaite pas répondre à tous vos
questions
faire un partenariat avec notre village
si vous ne voulez venir prendre
vous
êtes nos Muses
non on fait de la prospection
on vient
on va référencer se nourrir de votre
grandeur
n'avaient rien à offrir au monde mais si
si bien sûr
de trop précoce peut-être que ce que
nous verrons chez vous peut-être que
voilà on pourra partager des choses avec
vous mais pour l'instant je préfère être
honnête je préfère ne pas vous mentir et
vous promettre la lune vous voyez
peut-être parce que c'est la lune je
veux pas vous promettre le bout de la
ruelle mais peut-être que voilà
peut-être que la collaboration sera
fructueuse
et après peut-être que comment dire
est-ce que est-ce que vous pouvez nous
exposer un petit peu votre situation et
peut-être qu'on peut comprendre parce
que on est enfin on est des
différentes expertises qui peuvent aider
quoi voilà on a un petit peu comment ça
s'appelle cette émission là
un mix entre les parents Rangers et les
gens
qui font des meufs
[Rires]
voilà on a plein de compétences
verts on a une voilà comme a dit mon
collègue une expertise de nombreux
domaines voilà et que évidemment on est
prêt à partager mais à ce stade de la
MSB on ne peut pas vous promettre
des choses quoi d'accord donc vous êtes
ici pour fonder un partenariat long
terme finalement oui mais oui voilà
c'est super
Marius pourrait faire pour vous dans ce
cas
de confiance c'est comment
vous avez pu développer une agriculture
aussi florissante
premier point de la SB et ensuite on
nous a parlé de de complexe scientifique
souterrain
et je peux pas vous en dire trop mais
c'est des choses qui pourraient qui
pourrait aller avec nos propres projets
et sur lesquels on pourrait échanger
bâtir des relations
[Musique]
un échange d'information peut-être pas
leur dire que c'est ça
également on a poussé nos recherches pas
assez de la recherche fondamentale sur
mais qu'est-ce que le spolium et nous
avons des conclusions assez avancées qui
pourraient éventuellement intéresser un
village aussi pittoresque et magnifique
et productif que le vôtre disons qu'on
n'est pas dégueu chimie quoi voilà
d'accord je fais je fais un clin d'œil
[Musique]
tu regardes bizarre
si on pouvait rentrer en contact avec
vos scientifiques nous serions en mesure
de vous donner un peu ce que vous m'avez
dit le laboratoire souterrain c'était
une ancienne année du complexe Gaya mais
qui a été complètement abandonné donc
je me doute mais c'est encore une fois
je ne peux pas trop vous en dire mais à
des fins archéologiques
de comprendre un peu tout ce qui est
processus d'abonnement
[Applaudissements]
je pose la question
[Musique]
vous voulez visiter
des trucs
[Musique]
pour nous ça va être compliqué de vous
accompagner on a quand même beaucoup de
choses à faire c'est un petit village
quand même pas d'accord
dans la journée non plus quoi non non
d'accord je trouve pour aller se faire
une petite balade vous comprenez mais
c'est une MSB quand même par contre si
vous voulez que quelqu'un vous
accompagne jusqu'à l'entrée de Gaïa
c'est possible
ce serait charmant mais c'est ça on est
vraiment dans le coeur du tourisme j'ai
l'impression
au moment où vous dites ça
il y a des cloches qui commencent à
sonner à l'extérieur du village
et ça résonne beaucoup
ça commence à un peu s'agiter à
l'extérieur et les dirigeante elle
commence à un peu un peu stressé et du
coup il la voit non
s'il vous plaît
c'est pas plus que nous bah je sais pas
s'il y a des cloches
mais je vais vous demander de sortir et
on continue à sa discussion un peu plus
tard on va rester derrière vous oui
juste oui bon vous êtes libre de te
faire rapidement laisser passer ta
bouche vous êtes libre d'aller dans le
village mais nous on va travailler sur
tous d'accord très bien bon merci
on sort aussi et on regarde d'où vient
le citation et ce qui se passe alors au
moment où vous sortez du village elle
elle ferme la porte derrière vous et
puis elles vont faire discuter avec des
gens vous voyez que ça s'agite beaucoup
dans la rue qu'il y a des
tous les villageois qui courent presque
qui se réfugient chez eux qui
s'enferment certains dans des bâtiments
publics d'autres tornades
l'atmosphère est très bizarre ça sent le
brûler il y a des cendres qui tombent du
ciel
je regarde je vois un bâtiment public le
premier
que vois-je qu'est-ce que tu veux voir
une bibliothèque je vois une
bibliothèque bibliothèque ce serait plus
vers Gaïa alors je vois des écoles
je vois une école
je
vois une école une école je vois une
école je dis allons nous réfugier dans
l'école
[Musique]
est-ce que on peut demander au
professeurs
[Musique]
qu'est-ce qui se passe voilà et
tenez-loup tous vos livres éducatifs sur
l'histoire
on a laissé passer
mais du coup
c'est à dire qu'on étudie on est en
valeur
[Musique]
je regarde par les fenêtres qu'est-ce
que je vois là que moi ça évolue la
situation
tu vois qu'il y a des gardiennes du coup
qui commence
[Musique]
à ce que le disait sur Pompéi je regarde
par une fenêtre et je regarde le sommet
du monde niveau tu peux pas le voir mais
écoutez ils vont pas mettre un
générateur dans le cœur d'un volcan
j'espère que
tu sais ouais
c'est beaucoup comme ça
il y a de la cendre elle vient d'où
cette cendre
c'est une usine qui est en train de
la tête par la fenêtre et je fais comme
avec la neige je sors la langue et
j'essaie de choper un flocon est-ce que
ce serait pas un méga feu
merci églantine
est-ce que
[Musique]
j'allais en parler
j'ai vu une exposition dans mon passé
effectivement c'était auquel des savoirs
super exposition sur le feu feu mega feu
et qui parlait justement de toutes ces
problématiques du feu qui vont être
d'actualité cet été d'ailleurs
ces vêtements de pompiers
est-ce que je me tourne vers les
maîtresses
très spécifique
maman
[Rires]
les enseignantes et je leur dis vous
auriez pas par hasard une tenue de
protection
[Musique]
bien sûr donc on le laisse pas faire le
fait qu'il est facile quoi non mais
c'est la fatigue là c'est la fatigue
nerveuse ok
est-ce qu'on peut vous aider pour faire
quoi que ce soit
si vous avez une idée de qu'est-ce que
ça peut être et le problème
parce que ça peut être le volcan est-ce
qu'il est actif le volcan ou la montagne
[Musique]
[Rires]
des affaires et voir quel type de roche
il y a pour savoir l'intensité
[Musique]
les pompiers dans un si petit village
le problème c'est que on sait pas où il
est le feu est-ce qu'on peut passer un
coup de fil
il y a plus de
Facebook
je cherche
comment comment on peut pas joindre un
autre village
est-ce qu'il y a une fontaine quelque
part un bassin une bassine d'eau quelque
chose
est-ce que on peut prendre le chien
appuyer dessus on le met dans le puits
et comme ça il se remplit d'eau et après
on peut le faire
ils font des chats humaines ou pas mais
est-ce qu'on voit il voit pas là samedi
mais les champs ils sont bien éclairés
les champs ça va
trouver
partout avec notre torches et c'est tout
l'incendie
à moi qui fait de la lumière
est-ce que vous voulez pas faire une
recherche chercher à la chaleur chaud
froid
peut-être si si tu es très chaud
aujourd'hui ça produit ça produit du
vent normalement enfin la chaleur elle
fait des déplacements d'air mais alors
là pourquoi pourquoi c'est moi qui parle
de ça je sais pas il y a l'odeur il y a
la sensation de chaud et elle est il y a
les cendres est-ce que il se met à
sniffer dans une direction pas
spécialement
est-ce qu'on peut
Gloria je fais un jet perception pour
trouver le feu voilà c'est quoi ta
méthode du coup je prends la torche et
je regarde voir si je vois du du carbone
du carbone
de calcination quoi sur les choses
tu sors de la zone qui est éclairée
je prends églantine avec moi allez viens
ok fais un perception mais
enlève-toi 30% parce que bah d'accord
mais tu es sûr et certain que tu as
trouvé la source et tu avances il est là
le feu et tu as envie il est là
le feu
de vitesse dans une direction
il est là bas
[Musique]
chaleur
non
qu'est-ce qui peut prendre feu c'est un
endroit où il y a une activité
[Musique]
dans le coin
non on peut pas envoyer les enfants en
éclaireur
en haut du mont oui oui tranquillement
là-dedans
moi je regarde
est-ce qu'il y a des animaux qui je
regarde s'il y a des animaux qui courent
genre des petits mulots des trucs que
vous êtes dans dans une zone très petite
s'il y en a qui vont vous éviter quoi
qu'il arrive ils ont peur de vous oui
mais il fuit les flammes s'il fuit les
flammes ils vont s'en de passer
entre nos jambes non mais ils vont faire
un petit décalage pour éviter quoi du
coup tu es vu toi tu vois que à 2 mètres
de toi
est-ce que je peux entendre le feu et
faire un jeu de perception et le trouver
toi tu as fait un échec critique donc
c'est mort toi tu es persuadé que c'est
dans une direction et c'est raté les
autres ils peuvent faire des choses je
peux faire
c'est ça
ce serait le son
je pense
ou l'odeur on sent ça sent non je pense
qu'on l'a ça
[Musique]
dans le noir
et le spawium il réagit pas au feu c'est
du gaz c'est de la combustion
donc là je suis ok j'ai une idée
complémentaire c'est quoi ton idée
ça consomme de l'oxygène le spolium ça
brûle donc potentiellement ça consomme
de l'oxygène aussi si c'est si ça brûle
là comme ça donc mon idée c'est d'aller
dans des directions et de voir quand la
flamme de nos torches elle commence à
baisser ça veut dire qu'il y a moins
d'oxygène dans l'air mais ça veut dire
que tu es dans le feu se rapproche du
feu quoi je pense qu'on se sentir à ce
moment
oui c'est oui
malgré Pierre-Alain qui dit mais non
c'est par là je t'assure c'est pas
là en pression d'entendre des des bruits
de crépitement au loin mais pas du tout
dans la direction là que vous allez voir
et voilà OK
donc tu vois à peu près dans quelle
direction il y a du feu mais pas où
tu vas du coup bah non non on va pas
aller vers le feu tu peux tu peux nous
indiquer bah moi j'ai l'impression que
ça vient
de par là quoi
je sais pas comment s'appelle vers
générateur moi je dirais vers un endroit
qui
fait quelque chose
[Musique]
c'est abandonné
non écoutez parce que si c'est Gaïa mais
c'est pas où c'est Gaïa si elle nous
disait
avec la direction elle a trouvé le feu
ou pas
ce serait comme une forêt qui brûle
je sais pas on entouré de forêt enfin
j'essaie de c'est dans quelle direction
et si c'est pas les champs vous référez
pas spécialement
[Musique]
j'y vais moi je dis qu'il faut aller
vers Gaïa
par contre je sais pas je sais pas ce
qu'on fait là
on se retrouve au milieu
on se protège on les laisse gérer leur
méprise on peut peut-être leur juste
leur dire où est le feu du coup si tu es
sûr que oui on revient au village le feu
est là-bas
vous êtes les gens qui crient au feu au
feu et puis il y a pas de feu mais bon
c'est pas grave vous refaites tout le
trajet inverse de Pierre-Alain du coup
c'est quand même marcher longtemps dans
une direction parce qu'il avait l'air
très sur lui
donc faites tout le trajet inverse et
vous voyez en rentrant dans la zone
éclairée de dammaryllis que en fait le
feu il est en train de s'attaquer aux
champs que c'est bon là en fait
maintenant on voit d'où ils venait le
feu effectivement de la forêt de la
direction que tu voyais c'est juste que
là il a commencé à se propager
quelque chose
méthode c'est de leur demander elles
sont où les lanceurs ou quoi
faire de l'abattage de végétal préventif
là
est-ce qu'on préventif du coup pendant
qu'il réfléchissent moi je prends une
bassine je je sers à la fois toute la
ville
voilà
donc petit à petit vous vous éteignez
mais c'est un peu long OK et j'arrose
aussi les les façades des maisons qui
sont les plus proches du feu donc ah
ouais c'est pas bête ça je crois qu'il
faisait ça à l'époque bref il faut
fermer les fenêtres mettre des torchons
et des serpillières mouillés en bas
merci
aux habitants
[Applaudissements]
j'en profite aussi pour
des fois que
il va puer après voilà
[Musique]
du coup elle est en train de d'éteindre
des informations aux gens est-ce que toi
tu as envie de faire quelque chose non
moi je fais rien on attend là
je suis là
il y a plus de réserve
là
cette opération bassine ça ça a été un
doucement ok ils sont beaux
allez on continue
le puits
ok bon si vous faites rien de plus au
bout d'un moment vous finissez par pas
réussir à contenir le feu donc il va
juste continuer à se propager un peu
dans la forêt à de plus pour ça ils ont
au moins réussi à sauver les champs ou
une grande partie de ceux-là
les gens vous remercient parce que vous
êtes quand même des étrangers vous dites
merci quand même d'avoir mis la main à
la patte par rapport à c'est nous on a
juste gueulés
vous cacher
on a couru vers voilà vers le danger
et du coup on peut discuter avec les
habitants là ils sont sympas maintenant
et on peut vous savez d'où ça vient
vous savez ce qui a provoqué le feu une
idée
c'est jamais arrivé non il fait jamais
aussi chaud c'est vrai que tu es
particulièrement chaud aujourd'hui
comment ça se fait vous savez non c'est
bizarre parce que vous avez entendu
parler du réchauffement climatique pas
spécialement
un autre problème que le réchauffement
climatique c'est vrai qu'il fait tout
noir
mais c'est vrai que ça serait difficile
de reflète pas la vie de toute l'équipe
fasse tout noir tout le temps c'est vrai
que ça doit être un peu dur surtout au
début surtout si tu as en plus de
réchauffer où j'imagine
du coup
nous accompagner si on dit ah on va Yaya
ah bah oui génial
avec vous discutez et tout et puis il y
a une gardienne qui vous dit ah bah moi
je dois aller faire un rapport de toute
façon pour leur dire que c'est bon c'est
contenu donc si vous voulez une question
venez donc pendant qu'on marche pourquoi
il y a pourquoi il y a que des bonnes
femmes à la direction et dans l'armée
en bonne femme
pas du tout ah là je peux vous dire que
moi Joséphine elle aurait adoré faire
votre travail
c'est ma femme
Joséphine bon d'accord mais je suis
curieux ou quoi ça je trouve ça bien
sûr que votre avis compte beaucoup non
pas du tout
et du coup pourquoi
pourquoi pas je vous ai dit il y a pas
de réseau particulier c'est un homme
voulait devenir gardien c'est possible
non ah donc
c'est il y a une loi et c'est tout quoi
c'est comme ça
pas de problème à l'époque je suppose
c'est quoi
quand on est à Rome on est à Rome il y a
un dicton un peu comme ça je voulais
chemin en même temps non c'est pas
celui-là c'est le truc quand tu arrives
dans une ville tu enfin quand tu arrives
dans une robe comme un Romain ou un truc
c'est normal on pose pas de question on
fait comme ils font et c'est parti moi
je fais ça je dis ça
voilà comme à Rome
[Musique]
alors moi je trouve ça très bien
vous finissez par arriver à Gaillard
après maintes discussions d'abord juste
sur le chemin
vous croisez une espèce de bâtisse
ou d'ailleurs la gardienne elle trouve
ça bizarre parce que en fait tu as
d'habitude elle prend pas ce chemin
genre
vous avez pris un espèce de raccourci
vous êtes tombé devant une bâtisse et en
fait devant cette bâtisse il y a un
groupe de gardiennes qui sont en train
de sortir des gens de
gentiment violemment un peu violemment
qui sont attachés et elles sont en train
de les embarquer dans un véhicule
vous remarquez que tous les gens qui se
font embarqués ont une boucle d'oreille
en forme de sablier ah alors là surtout
ne rien dire bonjour mais bonjour
mesdames il faut pas se faire poser des
questions
là-bas je pense que là il faut observer
c'est pas votre problème ah d'accord et
il y en a un de ceux qui sont en train
de se faire embarquer quand ils vous
voient il se fige c'est celui que vous
avez croisé à iridis les mêmes personnes
qui dit c'est eux c'est eux qui font
qu'il faut arrêter c'est eux qui vont
détruire le monde ils vont créer un
paradoxe et au moment où il dit ça il y
a une gardienne qui lui en met une et
qui le balance dans la dans le véhicule
et ferme les portes et elles sont
complètement dingue
j'en profite pour me remettre le bandeau
en place et en même temps je fais un
doigt d'honneur à la voiture qui s'en va
pourquoi ils ont tous déshabiller dans
l'oreille
quelqu'un est-ce que quelqu'un veut
faire un jet de Perception une seule
personne
perceptionniste
bon les outils
donc moi même si je suis
percepteur je vois rien là non au moment
où en fait elles vont refermer la porte
du de la bâtisse il y a Clotilde Gloria
qui a jeté un coup d'oeil dans la dans
la Matisse mais elle a pas eu le temps
de voir quoi que ce soit
je m'adresse à une des gardiennes
on se rapproche du bâtiment je leur dis
vous avez bien fait de vous arrêter cela
vous les connaissez vaguement
[Musique]
le clan des sabliers
j'ai entendu dire que il faisait des
trucs d'accord le clan des sablier
après trois il a souvent un coup dans le
pif oui mais si Didier
mais je pense que c'est iridis qu'il
faut aller voir pour pour vous pencher
sur le nous on vient d'iris
je veux dire le lendemain il les
appelleraient
Paris Saint-Germain quoi
il se trouve qu'ils ont un sablier
ok continuons alors on va à Gaillard ok
vous continuez le chemin
je demande je me retourne vers l'une des
gardiennes et je dis excusez-moi est-ce
que je pourrais juste jeter un petit
coup d'œil à l'intérieur de la bâtisse
parce que vous voyez je cherche un T3 et
je voulais savoir si ce sera assez
spacieux parce que je trouve ça vraiment
vraiment charmant et pittoresque par
chez vous vous êtes sûr pourtant j'ai
plein de choses qui pourraient vous
intéresser
c'est pas pour votre entreprise vous
cherchez des locaux
économique de la région juste un petit
œil comme ça rapidement pour voir un peu
la superficie des locaux les volumes les
dirigeants
qui pourraient peut-être fait un mentir
convaincu
je suis à 75
les gens
c'est juste on est quand même là pour le
tourisme
si pour le tourisme macabre
avec des crimes
combien d'étoiles combien de crapauds
[Rires]
des locaux pour votre guide si on
pouvait avoir un petit récit à se mettre
sous la dent ah oui donner envie comment
des héroïnes ont arrêté le clan des
sabliers qui terrorisaient la région et
qui mettait le feu le Grand
Tout cette journaliste
alors c'est plus que pour notre guide
touristique qui va vous amener beaucoup
de retombées économiques dans votre
région
si ça vous intéresse je vous invite à
venir discuter à la caserne tout à
l'heure mais pour l'instant là on est il
faut qu'on s'occupe d'eux elle se trouve
la caserne dans le village dans le
village
et bon boulot
[Rires]
OK
une fois que vous arrivez à la porte
c'est un espèce de grand bâtiment en fer
la porte est fermée
[Musique]
qui accueillent la personne qui la
gardienne qui avec vous
oui
nous venons du pour une MSB une mission
secrète de botanique
voilà nous avons laissé passer de la
part des dirigeantes pour peut-être
établir un partenariat sur un terme de
recherche
Botanico agricole l'eau économique
de ce que tu as dit donc vous avez
laissé passer
[Musique]
ok d'accord bon bah bienvenue à
gaillards
peut-être une Hélène ça vous parle
copine de fac
[Musique]
c'est pas grave on va pas détailler
elle vous amène donc vous passez un peu
dans des couloirs toi tu remarques que
ça il y a la construction elle ressemble
un peu à
Elixia l'air de rien genre c'est un peu
structuré de la même façon c'est juste
que en fait le même contracteur c'est
fait autour d'un grand jardin central en
fait
j'aimerais bien aller voir le jardin moi
donc tout le temps tu te barres en gros
genre non mais vous vous le voyez à
travers des vitres
de spolium en fait c'est leur c'est la
recette bah oui amaryllis oui non mais
eux c'est des scientifiques qui ont une
autre méthode ça une autre
développeurs
du coup qui vous accueille qui vous
disent bonjour Hélène ma petite Hélène
ça fait plaisir de te revoir
de la
avec vous qui s'en va du coup ok et tu
parle un petit peu
[Rires]
on vient de la part de Céline en fait on
était on était à Elixia et Céline vous
connaissez Céline
[Musique]
heureuse et voulu manquer beaucoup et on
l'a trouvé en train de d'admirer sa
bague
une belle bague en j'ai pas noté en quoi
c'était juste rouge
en rubis d'accord et
elle voulait que qu'on vous dise de sa
part que elle est très malheureuse et
que elle a très envie de vous rejoindre
me rejoindre c'est la saison 3
après on peut pas parler pour elle
la position délicate dans laquelle nous
sommes
juste des messagers
et elle nous a demandé enfin de vous
demander de nous accompagner dans le
complexe
et dans les soutiens
c'est une vieille connaissance de madame
elle aimerait vous rejoindre mais elle
veut s'assurer que le complexe il est au
nord que il y a pas de danger et donc
elle nous a dit ça c'est tous ses lignes
[Musique]
Fredo je vous confie la tâche de
vous assurer que le complexe il est au
nord
que la RT 2012 est respectée
que les normes ISO 9712 elles sont en
place d'accord bah écoutez dans ce cas
j'accepte
de travail du coup on avait j'aimerais
commencer par les souterrains parce que
c'est toujours les les moments un peu de
faiblesse des bâtiments les souterrains
vous voulez parler de l'annexe de
l'annexe
je lui demande parce qu'elle est un peu
elle est construite un petit peu trop
loin et que ça servait pas à grand chose
pour les recherches sur les plantes mais
allons-y et vous allez vous raconter sur
moi je refuse de rentrer là-dedans mais
c'est complètement désaffecté c'est
super dangereux non pas accompagner nous
jusque là
je sais pas si c'est utile qu'on y a
vraiment tous parce que si vous voulez y
aller vraiment pour vérifier vous pouvez
mais oui
m'a confié de vraiment bien être Faro
elle m'a dit c'est de l'anglais elle m'a
dit
Fredo
[Musique]
be follow brise du coup si vous voulez
qu'on aille
qu'on aille cette annexe c'est à 20
minutes d'ici à pied
on peut y aller si vous voulez
être important quand même oui je veux
dire que ce soit 20 minutes tout de
suite ou 20 minutes dans 30 minutes ce
sera toujours on sépare chacun notre
aventure et on se donne rendez-vous dans
une heure ici quoi je parle à l'abri à
mes camarades c'est vous qui étiez
attendu dans les souterrains après vous
allez où vous voulez mais théoriquement
la lettre était pourrie l'histoire là
c'est
moi j'ai des absences
de changer complètement mon avis sur la
question on peut passer par le jardin
peut-être et puis
c'est vrai peut-être que Fredo vous
pouvez m'accompagner ou alors un
glantine vous m'accompagnez
on va passer par le jardin avant tout
est-ce qu'on peut juste demander est-ce
que vous pouvez nous faire un topo
de comment ça marche Gaïa tout ça votre
projet
voilà en marchant
vous passez par le jardin vu que tu le
demandes un gros jardin où il y a il y a
juste des plantes qui se développent
tranquille je peux regarder un peu ouais
ouais il y en a beaucoup de cul tu
connais même si tu saurais pas je suis
sûr
elle meurt
parents ils étaient agriculteurs
donc ton montre une par exemple ouais
connaissance de la nature
et non c'est une carotte
n'est pas un hibiscus
oui
l'éclairage spolium ça me oui d'accord
donc du coup tu vois qu'il y a en fait
il y a des endroits où ça pousse un peu
en à l'arrache quoi j'ai envie de dire
c'est libre quoi
ou c'est un peu plus rangé tu vois qu'il
y a un peu plus des études qui sont
faites sur le truc notamment il y en a
certes il y a des serres qui sont
entièrement éteinte
mais dites-moi Hélène pourquoi tout cet
arrangement
on fait plein de tests sur comment
évolue la nature dans ce nouveau monde
ah oui donc la lumière c'est pour
simuler exactement et ça donne quoi
ça donne quoi en gros ce qu'on a vu il y
a
une partie des plantes qui ont disparu
il y en a une bonne partie qui sont
restés en état un peu de stase genre un
peu comme une hibernation si vous voulez
et au final elle réagissent assez bien
l'éclairage au spodium qui a l'air de
déclencher leur photo de base
normalement c'est plein de trucs
follicules elles ont besoin d'être non
c'est une carotte encore une fois
j'allais dire c'est les carottes
follicules qui ne sont pas concernés
parce que elles ont besoin d'avoir un
éclairage assez fort c'est pour ça que
vous avez peut-être vu que les champs
sont très bien éclairées
et il y en a d'autres du coup qui ont
muté et qui maintenant utilise
un nouveau système appelé la
thermosynthèse
la chaleur au lieu de d'utiliser la
lumière simplement et donc on fait plein
de tests on voit comment elle réagissent
aux particules noires etc pour pour
s'assurer d'être prospère
elle vient d'où cette chaleur peut-être
d'un feu du soleil et du sol d'accord et
du sol hier
vous a accompagné
et votre Spadium vous vous le procurer
où
[Musique]
j'ai d'autres questions
qu'on devrait en avoir mais j'aimerais
bien rejeter un oeil à cet hibiscus
quand même
c'est pas de l'hibiscus je crois ça
c'est de l'hibiscus
je fais 32
est-ce que amaryllis
et c'est oui d'ailleurs je devais te
laisser quelques mots je suis allé
descendante retrouve-moi dans ce
laboratoire secret tu devrais te
débrouiller seul pour le trouver
malheureusement faut juste qu'on trouve
toute façon
mais pas seul au monde bon continuez
vers
l'annexe ok on vous sortez de Gaïa en
fait vous marchez sur un espèce de petit
frère sentier
et vous finissez par arriver donc vous
éclairez avec votre torche dans le
trajet j'ai une belle torche est-ce que
je peux la mettre en verte
petit temps est-ce qu'on a encore avec
crapaud vert
est-ce qu'on a encore avec Hélène
et qu'elle peut me rejoindre quand elle
va d'accord pourquoi vous voulez pas
aller à Elixia pourquoi vous voulez pas
la rejoindre je suis parti
et qu'est-ce que ça vous apporte de
d'aller ailleurs qu'est-ce que ça vous
apporte à vivre dans ce monde plutôt que
d'essayer de régler un problème il
résolvable
moi je sers à la société ici
[Musique]
vous n'auriez pas une bague précieuse à
nous à nous confier pour justement pas
pourquoi est-ce que vous pensez que
parce qu'il y a pas de futur dans la
démarche d'élixia de s'y trouver une
solution enfin c'est vos recherches qui
vous indiquent oui il n'y a pas d'espoir
là-dedans de toutes les recherches qu'on
a fait en fait ce qu'on a compris c'est
que
les particules noires viennent d'une
réaction
qui est due aux émissions de panoral
dans l'atmosphère de
on l'a vu à l'école mais je me souviens
plus moi c'est ça s'écrit commun
c'est pas normal c'est pas
normal
vienne les parties noires viennent de la
combustion c'est ça
de ce qu'on a compris enfin pour nous
c'est limpide que c'est ça et donc moi
la production de spolium relâche de sa
bretmosphère ah donc c'est un cercle
beaucoup une fois que ça a été un peu
trop saturé dans l'atmosphère ça a créé
une réaction de Lord Holt tu coup on
s'est retrouvé avec les particules
noires et ben maintenant c'est trop tard
maintenant le spolium est Vidal c'est
comme ça donc on va pas faire le seul
moyen ce serait enfin malheureusement
une réaction de London on ne peut pas
l'inverser sauf en réinjectant une des
deux matières originale sauf que il y en
a une des deux c'est l'atmosphère et
l'atmosphère on va pas pouvoir en
réinjecter donc soit il faut vivre dans
le noir
très longtemps en espérant que ça change
mais il y a pas de changement
soit il faut utiliser du spolium pour
vivre et du coup ça continue ça
entretient le exactement c'est
dramatique sauf que c'est tellement
vital que on s'est dit bah tant pis
d'accord
vous avez dit une réaction de de looser
mais
non et donc vous avez dit pour
l'inverser il faudrait
déjà ce serait enfin de ce qu'on a de ce
qu'on apprend avec la chimie c'est
quelque chose de temporaire seulement
l'inversé
c'est-à-dire que si on brise l'équilibre
ça inverse la réaction de l'envolte et
au bout d'un moment l'équilibre finit
par se retrouver lui-même donc quoi
qu'il arrive c'est mort c'est pour ça
que du coup quand on fait brûler du
spolium en fait ça inverse localement la
réaction de l'envolt du coup on y voit
mais c'est temporaire la réaction de
quoi je comprends pas le mot
landaulte d'accord
[Rires]
changer quelque chose pour ne pas finir
dans cette situation
qui fasse tout noir partout de ce que
les livres en disent c'était un une
source d'énergie
très propre
parce que le Père Noël ne semblait pas
dangereux d'accord à l'époque des tests
et c'était le seul rejet donc rien de
bien grave et en plus de ça la
combustion est très lente du coup il y a
pas besoin d'en produire beaucoup pour
faire beaucoup d'énergie donc très
pratique comme source d'énergie c'est
pour ça que c'est assez développé très
fort et puis après il y a eu le un Club
de Rome comme un Romain qui a dit ah oui
mais non en fait il y a du pain normal
c'est pas bon mais personne n'a écouté
j'en sais rien en tout cas moi je pense
c'est ça on un peu là ce genre de cas de
figure donc en fait il faudrait revenir
dans le passé et dire aux gens stop ne
créez pas du spodium en créant par
exemple
est-ce que vous savez faire des voyages
dans le temps mais
je sais que il y a des fous du complexe
iNEXIA qui disent que ça existe
des gens qui ne sont pas capables
d'accepter le changement
juste fictionnelle c'est à dire que si
on pouvait renvoyer quelqu'un dire
faites pas du spodium ça réglerait tout
le problème
faudrait qu'il y aille avec une preuve
parce que qu'est-ce qu'il faudrait leur
dire
qu'est-ce que qu'est-ce qui prouverait
aux gens finalement je sais pas
peut-être faire des tests plus
approfondis sur le paranormal dans des
environnements plus fermés pour ça veut
dire qu'il va falloir qu'on soit lanceur
d'alerte
quelle horreur
pour vous il y a que à Elixia qu'on
croit au voyage dans le temps en tout
cas je connais pas beaucoup d'autres
villages donc peut-être que ailleurs
dans le monde oui aussi mais on a croisé
des rigolos sur la route avec un sablier
dans l'oreille et ce que c'est chaud
alors ça c'était curieux c'était
vraiment étonnant ils sont partis dans
un bus peut-être que c'était une fanfare
ce sont des saltins banques
vous finissez par arriver devant une
espèce de grande trappe dans sur le sol
donc Hélène elle vous dit bon ben voilà
c'est ici
il y a un cadenas mais en fait c'est
ouvert
la dernière personne a part du remettre
la chaîne mais c'est pas très grave
elle ouvre ça et elle vous dit voilà bon
moi je préfère pas descendre parce que
j'ai pas envie de prendre de risques
parce que je n'ai pas de souci
vous vous doutez bien qu'un laboratoire
souterrain désaffecté depuis plusieurs
années
vous n'auriez pas un casque enfin quatre
casques sur vous c'est un peu tard
ça c'est souvent chez nous
merci Hélène on se retrouve pour le café
ça marche bah faites attention à vous
là-dessous quand même attention
quand même au voyage dans le temps
voilà sur ce cette parole nous nous
enfonçons
ok en régie ça me rappelle un truc que
j'ai complètement oublié potentiel de
pose est-ce que ça
fait mal
après la pause
5 minutes
de prendre une trappe vous êtes descendu
vous allez refermer derrière vous et
vous arrivez dans un espèce de complexe
souterrain qui est allumé il est
alimenté au spodium que faire les
économies
pour l'instant il y a juste un long
couloir
qui mène à une porte
que fait églantine il est comment là
de temps en temps
je macroupis et je pose la main sur le
sol de quelle nature est-il comme
lorsque
c'est du métal
genre un petit caillou qui traîne un
truc comme ça
des agitateurs magnétiques qui sont
dedans depuis le début d'accord et je
les fais rebondir sur le sol pour qu'ils
avancent c'est comme ça si jamais il y a
des mines antipersonnelles
[Applaudissements]
ok on continue
ouais ce qu'on peut faire c'est donc a
priori moi j'ai des amis ici enfin je
veux dire c'est ma décembre quoi c'est
devant je suis parti
ça résonne mais il y a pas de réponse
alors peut-être vu qu'il y a un couloir
et une Porsche propose qu'on avance vers
la porte il faut qu'on avance générale
pour que on puisse mettre par exemple
une jambe d'un côté une jambe de l'autre
sur les cloisons sans toucher le
parcours le sol bon bah tant pis je
marche normalement
[Rires]
je veux m'appuyer sur les murs pour
éviter les mines à j'appuie sur un
bouton rouge
dans une espèce de salle qui est un peu
circulaire
ça ressemble à ce que je connais en
termes pas du tout pas du tout par
contre
faites moi un jeu d'intelligence
je sais pas 16
tout ça je ne vous ça vous dit rien vous
deux
vous vous rendez compte qu'en fait les
il y a des machines au milieu de cette
salle ils sont branchés un peu tout
n'importe comment machine
énormément aux installations de Gaston
ça vous rappelle pas quelque chose Fredo
ça me rappelle ce qu'il y avait dans le
labo de Gaston quoi c'est les mêmes
machines
débloquer des choses on essaye de
regarder autour voir s'il y a des gens
vous n'avez pas compris tous les mots
qui sont les installations comme chez
Gaston il y a une porte enfin il y a
quatre portes en fait sur les quatre
côtés de chacun
puis on a une c'est celle de vous
d'ouvrez une elle est fermée et vous
avez pas l'air de pouvoir l'ouvrir et
des autres c'est des chèvres derrière il
y en a une qui mène à une grande salle
sombre où vous y voyez rien bonne façon
et
sur une salle où il y a une radio qui
joue une petite musique ah vous entendez
une petite mélodie qu'est-ce qu'on
entend ce serait pas le générique de mot
de passe
sous le vent
c'est que c'est fini
ça vous dit pas quelque chose cette
chanson ouais incroyable
enfin karaoké
du vinaigre c'est ça c'est ça c'est la
merde
du coup vous avancez bon c'est un petit
poste qui a l'air de jouer une cassette
je tourne la torche que j'ai allumé
entre temps je regarde
la torche
bon il y a rien dans la salle quoi on
écoute la petite cassette
ces écrans vous vous reconnaissez qu'en
fait c'est un peu des sortes de caméras
de surveillance qui sont reliés à tout
le complexe Gaïa et aussi donc au
couloir et à la salle dans laquelle vous
étiez juste avant et vous vous voyez
vous même sur un écran alors là c'est
creepy creepy
j'en profite pour me faire un petit snif
de ma torche
pour te détendre ouais pour le stress
moi je rembobine la cassette je m'ajoute
5% d'addiction
vous remarquez aussi qu'il y a beaucoup
d'écriture un peu écrites sur les murs
sur des tableaux etc mais
incompréhensible ça a l'air d'être des
médecins qui ont écrit
des équations
de toi
je crois qu'on appelle ça
fait coup de pelle
[Musique]
ou des photos de lui bébé en couche
est-ce qu'elles sont entourées en rouge
genre iridis c'est pas tu sais pas trop
en fait c'est-à-dire une tête de bébé
200 ans
de Pierre Alain mais oui je vous ai dit
depuis
mais non maintenant on est dans un
environnement un peu enfin je veux dire
hostile ouais parce que je veux dire
c'est pas c'est pas chaleureux en place
hein dans une salle avec des caméras
partout non portrait de vous
cauchemar dans le bon moi je les
admirateurs
que j'allume
je vais dans la pièce à côté il y a rien
d'autre dans ce sale donc il y a Fredo
il va dans une pièce à côté mais on le
regarde mais moi je regarde mes photos
bah vous le voyez plus ah parce que toi
tu vois toujours mais tu avances et il
voit plus ma torche oui mais en fait tu
as beaucoup avancé quoi ah oui c'est une
grande de ça je me positionne à l'entrée
de la porte et je fais eh oh
j'entends je fais oui mais je fouille
hein
et là je fouille donc seul je vais pas
de toute façon tu rejoins Fredo ouais
j'ai la torche magique monsieur si je
parti
mon truc mais moi c'est juste que j'ai
mon j'ai ma descendante qui m'a dit
voilà
j'ai pu créer une brèche dans
l'espace-temps qui m'a permis de voir le
passé le temps d'un instant faut que je
garde cette trouvaille secrète sinon les
scientifiques du coin vont vouloir s'en
servir pour leur intérêt mais j'ai un
meilleur plan j'ai entendu parler d'un
ancien laboratoire ce terrain
sur laboratoire je vais m'y installer
pour finir mes recherches et contacter
Pierre Alain bon d'ailleurs je vais lui
laisser ces quelques notes notes si tu
lis ces mots je suis ta descendre
retrouve-moi dans le laboratoire secret
tu vas devoir te débrouiller seul pour
le trouver malheureusement bah on l'a
trouvé donc elle est là dedans on est
dans le mais moi je enfin tous les mots
nous parlent maintenant donc vous deux
là vous êtes dans la salle tous les deux
qu'est-ce que vous cherchez de
spécifiquement voir je sais pas
interrupteur des des trucs de spolium
qu'on peut mettre des piles que tu veux
pouvoir rien tu en fait tu te balades la
salle elle a l'air un peu vide il y a
pas des étagères des choses comme ça des
objets des bibelots j'appelle je fais il
y a quelqu'un genre tu regardes à quel
niveau de la salle genre plutôt vers le
sol plutôt vers tous les murs ok ça a
l'air d'être assez dix dans l'ensemble
d'un coup pendant que vous deux vous
êtes en train de parler là de Thanos tu
vois une personne d'un coup se faufiler
à tes côtés pousser Gloria dans la salle
Gloria et la porte se ferme
et ça s'allume d'un coup oh
il y a de l'eau qui est un train de
remplir la salle
avec une femme du coup de l'autre côté
est-ce que vous savez nager
dans la salle la pièce centrale j'essaie
de d'enfoncer la porte
j'ai des pieds de biche la femme te
regarde
c'est moi Lucie votre descendance Lucie
mais qu'est-ce que pourquoi
madame Lucie s'il vous plaît laissez les
sorties
pourquoi faire mais parce que j'ai
on serait pas arrivé jusqu'ici on n'aura
pas pu résoudre
je peux pas les lâcher tu comprends
qu'on pourrait changer la face d'horizon
en rentrant ensemble changer la face
d'horizon en rentrant ensemble le pied
de biche là
[Rires]
je t'explique
je suis au point sur mon mécanisme de
voyage temporel ah bon tu as du temps
rendre compte quand je suis venu te voir
dans le passé
c'était totalement rendu compte mon
premier test qui a plutôt bien marché
même s'il n'est pas pu rester très
longtemps d'accord maintenant je suis au
courant si on rentre ensemble
moi j'ai pas envie de vivre de vivre
dans ce monde pourri ah mais
comprends-il donc tu me ramènes dans le
passé
je reconstruis ma technologie dans le
et on se sert de ça pour voir si tu es
chaud en tant que président de la CCI
d'horizon ont des impacts bénéfiques ou
négatifs dans le futur mais alors ça
veut dire
que je peux pas seulement devenir
président de CCI
mais président
du monde potentiellement
alors là Lucie
on a peut-être un marché
qu'est-ce qu'il faut faire là dites-moi
tout Lucie
moi je le fais confiance à mon ancêtre
comme on dit c'est le sang
alors Lucie Lucie Lucie
comment on a réussi
moi j'ai le problème parce que je suis
venu avec trois personnes ici oui mais
tu en as pas vraiment besoin alors non
non
est-ce que
[Rires]
on peut éviter de leur faire trop mal
pour l'instant le temps qu'on
réfléchisse qu'on voit un peu comme ce
qu'on fait on pourra réfléchir une photo
on les sauve d'une manière ou d'une
autre enfin je veux dire là ils vont
c'est trop bon
du coup qu'est-ce qu'on peut voyager dès
aujourd'hui dès maintenant dans le temps
là tout de suite
et bien je pense que le plus simple ce
serait d'utiliser la technologie de
Gaston pour passer inaperçu ah ouais
mais Gaston il est à l'horizon
on a du mal à se dire que ça va bien
aller
donc donc du coup donc ça veut dire
qu'il faut qu'on aille voir Gaston
sa technologie vous le convainquez de me
renvoyer dans le passé avec vous ouais
on est d'accord moi j'ai juste entendu
des temporelles
la porte non c'est une porte un peu sur
truc hydraulique là il y a pas des
conduits au plafond d'aération il y a
des candidats
ou un humain peut passer j'ai une corde
va être compliqué mais c'est faisable
de toute façon moi je continue de parler
avec Lucie
moi je suis par terre
dans 26 pas besoin de bonus je suis très
persépitif
tu détournes les yeux et tu vois sur une
des un des écrans dans la salle d'à côté
tu vois tes trois camarades avec de
l'eau jusqu'à la taille qui sont en
train de taper sur la porte et de
regarder un peu partout Lucie
c'est quoi qu'est-ce qui se passe
pourquoi ils sont dans une piscine là
parce que c'est plus simple de les
éliminer comme ça les éliminer
comment comment vous dire Lucie
c'est que c'est qu'en fait j'ai pas mal
de
voilà de pas de vécu mais juste voilà
c'est des gens qui sont
partenariats intéressants
et qui pourrait aider notre entreprise
familiale à prospérer
et vous êtes sûr qu'il serait enfin pour
moi ils m'ont jamais accepté quand je
rentre dans le passé avec vous mais
pourquoi pas ils sont cool c'est Gloria
Gloria
des machins vous voyez trois mots
d'archéologie va être ok Fredo bon voilà
quoi et églantine donnez-lui un escalope
de
escalope de poulet et puis franchement
alors ils sont bons dans leur spécialité
mais alors
voilà on peut un peu leur
leur envoyer du flan quoi d'accord et
sont pas là comme ça mais ils sont
débrouillards
de pression si vous êtes 4 ce sera plus
moi mais attendez c'est moi c'est moi
qui l'ai contrôle là les trois là c'est
mesbire c'est
[Musique]
pourquoi
que l'eau ne monte plus si c'est
possible ok elle appuie sur un truc et
ça arrête le coup vous vous voyez juste
l'eau qui arrête de se remplir vous
l'avez à peu près au niveau du ventre
moi j'ai envie d'essayer là le conduit
de l'ouvrir et au moins regarder où ça
c'est en haut du mur ok je vous fais la
courte
échelle pied-de-biche
moi
qui la soulève 22
83 sur 40 donc du coup je retombe dans
l'eau il te lèvent tu perds l'équilibre
et tu retombes ok
[Musique]
contrôle
enfin est-ce que je peux parler est-ce
que je demande à Lucie est-ce que je
peux parler parce que je peux leur
parler dans un petit micro
potentiellement oui je peux leur parler
ça dépend pour dire quoi bah pour leur
dire de se calmer parce que là vous
voyez bien qu'ils sont en train ils vont
se faire mal c'est c'est lesbire ils
sont pas voilà vraiment elle t'amène
dans la salle d'à côté du coup là où il
y a tous les écrans et elle branche le
truc et elle te dit elle te montre je te
ressemble à un micro ok alors gloglo
Fredo
profitez-en
comment tu les entends pas par contre
oui oui mais calmez-vous restez dans
l'eau je suis en train de parler avec
quelqu'un qui s'appelle Lucie elle est
très sympa franchement gros délire
je vais vous sortir de là dans deux
secondes
il y a il y a pas il y a pas de problème
laissez-moi juste finir ça essayez pas
de grimper partout parce que je vous
vois franchement c'est ridicule j'en
profite pour faire quelques brasses
bouga dans les bras parce que il est
obligé de nager donc je le prends ok
donc
bon ils ont effectivement l'air de vous
obéir donc je pense que je peux vous
faire confiance là-dessus
[Rires]
donc du coup avec ma petite troupe là ça
voudrait dire qu'on va avoir Gaston
on lui dit quoi on lui dit salut c'est
nous
renvoie nous dans le passé et c'est tout
je suppose qu'il vous a déjà dit que
vous pourriez rentrer dans le passé
ouais mais alors en super contact avec
le général Beaulieu là oui mais on n'est
pas obligé de passer devant général vous
connaissez vous avez vos entrées quoi si
on va directement au labo ah oui ok donc
on va au labo et c'est bon quoi oui
dans ce cas là on fait ça comme ça on
retourne tous dans le
dans le passé notre présent ce serait
plus sympa ok bon on peut les libérer
mesbires maintenant parce que je pense
qu'ils sont assez assez mouillés
d'accord je pense que je peux vous faire
confiance
tenez j'ai quand même essayer d'attenter
à leur vie vous comprendrez que oh non
il prendront pas mal je vous assure que
l'active de 3 trucs vous d'un coup il y
a des grilles en fait qui s'ouvrent au
sol et ça fait couler l'eau très vite
donc ça s'évapit ça s'évacue je m'en
rends pas compte tout de suite et je
continue à faire un peu
dans le grand
un peu de crawl aussi
la porte s'ouvre ok ok là je fais
ah mais c'est bien
on s'exprime
est-ce que vous pouvez vous occuper de
Fredo parce que là
ça me prend la tête un truc de fou alors
églantine ça va mais qu'est-ce qui s'est
passé
un accident un bête accident vous a
poussé dedans quand même qu'est-ce qui
vous est arrivé
tout va bien faut faire surveiller votre
oreille interne
donc je vous présente Lucie Lucie la
descendance
un petit petit mais il y a un air de
famille
et donc
là la petite chichette elle a trouvé un
moyen de nous ramener dans le dans le
présent et oui
bon déjà le sang
ça me semble un facteur important non
mais on peut pas ramener des gens du
futur dans le passé enfin
proposé de nous accompagner
dans voir Gaston et elle détient
quelques quelqu'un quelques moyens
techniques pour aider le transfert à se
faire c'est gentil mais faut parfois
s'enfermer par contre
le coup de l'eau et tout ça va un peu
des accidents
on peut le transmettre à Gaston
nous-même peut-être non c'est mon
invention
non mais ça va bien se passer qu'est-ce
que qu'est-ce que vous apportez
concrètement à notre programme
ici pas ici mais je peux donner avec les
machines de Gaston lui peut pas mais
vous vous pouvez je suis vraiment désolé
parce que généralement ils sont pas
comme ça c'est juste dès qu'ils sont
mouillés
on y va ouais donc vous comprenez bien
le plan
les
on va voir Gaston
pour qu'il nous amène dans le présent
dans des pierres on est venu ici voir
votre descendants
chichi et puis non à chaque fois
forcément parce que nous entendiez pas
j'ai eu que j'ai entendu quelques Bang
Bang mais pas plus
vous m'envoyez désolé
mais sincère excuses enfin Lucie c'est
pas cool mais ce billard
oui mais bon moi j'y peux rien ça
reste un lieu désaffecté c'est dangereux
mais oui mais surtout les salles qui
sont plus alimentées
de quoi là j'ai pas tout compris il y
avait combien de consonnes dans ce mot
[Musique]
pour qu'elle comprenne que
ok parce que voilà et ben pas du tout
68 sur 40
tu comprends pas ce qu'elle essaie de
faire en fait tu la vois qu'elle a de
son pied contre ton tibia et tu sais pas
ce qu'elle fait franchement
on reconnaît donc c'est les mêmes
machines que chez travaille sur les
voyage temporelles j'ai réussi d'accord
et pourquoi cette note là pour Pierre
Alain
parce que je veux je voulais
je suis une proposition d'être quand
même enfin mais en quoi ça consiste
précisément votre aide quel est
l'élément que vous apportez à la machine
de Gaston j'ai inventé les voyages
temporels inverse
votre ami
mon ancêtre Pierre-Alain peut vous en
parler d'ailleurs je pense que je suis
rentré en contact avec lui bien avant
que vous venez ici ah bon c'est
précurseur première nouvelle
une personne humanoïde et c'était Lucie
je vous avais raconté tout ça ah oui
mais on vous croyez pas
c'est vrai que oui
ça tourne aussi il faut être réveillé
quand même pour parler à hauteur donc
simplement je savais que Pierre Alain
allait finir par revenir ici donc moi je
voulais simplement me proposer de
l'aider à rentrer chez lui
c'est la famille parfait bon bah
allons-y non on est un peu la famille
maintenant aussi
Pierre Alain
alors
oui oui oui tout à fait oui
et oui et d'ailleurs ça me fait penser
vite qu'on aille dans le présent qu'on
puisse célébrer tout ça dans le présent
mais
ok
vous êtes tombés sur maths
j'avais dit de pas y toucher
voilà spalium
c'est pas pour vous ce truc là
c'est trop de famille trop de
l'air libre un peu parce que moi
on va tous dans le véhicule et hop
direction horizon
et on les empêche de brûler
ah non mais le but c'est juste nous en
retour après vous faites ce que vous
voulez si vous voulez délier votre vie à
une cause voilà compliqué vous faites
moi je ne cessé à faire tourner bah moi
je suis pas très chaud que le monde y
devienne comme ça quoi personnel on est
en vue Amélie je me dis que le monde est
pas mal comme il est
Gloria
allons à l'air libre ce sera mieux je
pense pour tout le monde
vous sortez vous voulez retourner à Gaïa
ou d'abord où vous allez directement
choper un véhicule
moi je repasserai bien voir la caserne
ah oui voir
les diamants des oreilles Les
Sables-d'Olonne
je suis en train de me dire d'accord
touristiques
on peut faire un dernier petit tour et
après on va à horizon parfait
est-ce qu'on peut passer à Gaia avant et
jeudi à l'abri de 2 là juste à vous deux
pour se renseigner sur cette Lucie
savoir s'ils ont entendu parler de ça
pue alors est-ce que moi je peux essayer
de leur parler
moi je pense que
peut pas faire sans elle et elle elle
n'a pas besoin de nous
on comprenait
[Rires]
je suis conscient
je pense qu'elle ne nous fait pas
confiance
on dit que on avait on devait voir laine
elle va s'inquiéter si on va pas la voir
Hélène on doit lui porter un agitateur
magnétique qu'elle nous avait demandé
mais on va une corde non non
Lucie il faut qu'on avant de retourner à
Marylis il faut qu'on repasse par Gaïa
parce que il y a Hélène qui nous attend
il faut simplement qu'on aille lui faire
un compteur en dû
c'est d'ordre administratif
si vous voulez vous nous attendez là on
fait juste un aller-retour on lui dit ok
c'est bon et puis on revient ok
on y va tous les deux ou vous voulez
venir avec nous
ralentir
on y va
un peu en vitesse
ok donc vous retrouvez Hélène du coup
Hélène alors ça c'est bien passé votre
visite alors
un terme de sécurité on est bon par
contre
l'annexe elle est pas abandonnée
autre chose non dans les registres vous
savez si on peut regarder des registres
quelque part rapidement là on a pas
beaucoup de temps
la liste du personnel
liste des à Noël là vous savez quand
vous faites des grandes cérémonies tout
ça peut-être mais on pourrait avoir
accès à ça si vous passez une question
de vie ou de mort d'accord bon écoutez
Hélène il y avait quelqu'un dans les
souterrains OK et donc un squatteur un
peu dangereux
[Musique]
peut-être a pris un mauvais tour dans
mais oui mais bon désolé mais bâtiment
est abandonné
d'accord mais genre à partir du moment
où nous on a décidé que le bâtiment il
est plus à nous on va plus l'utiliser
oui il y avait s'il y a quelqu'un qui va
dedans on y peut rien quoi si ça reste
sur vos terres ça reste vos
responsabilités est-ce que c'est moi à
renvoyer vos cours de droit quoi ou
alors peut-être qu'à la caserne on
demande s'il y a pas est-ce que la
caserne c'est pas aussi un commissariat
et que peut-être aller rechercher
[Musique]
merci au revoir alors bon
la sécurité c'est bon on s'occupe de
retourner voir Céline
et pas de souci merci vous avez un
message à lui faire passer peut-être
plus de souvenir simplement c'est tout
je pense qu'on se parlera une fois que
on se retrouvera vous êtes on se
retrouve
merci Céline merci beaucoup Hélène
Hélène merci Céline c'est ce que je
dirais votre épouse
donc là on repart et je dis vous
retrouvez les trois là
je lui dis bon moi j'ai toujours pas
confiance dans celui-ci il faut comme
ville dis-je en faisant flop flop avec
mes chaussures mouillées
je pense il faut qu'on se renseigne à
Marylise quoi ouais je crois aussi mais
la caserne les gardiennes pour commencer
est-ce que vous pensez
est-ce que vous pensez qu'elle peut
avoir un rapport avec le feu
le feu
point d'interrogation
vous allez vers la caserne du coup et en
fait devant la caserne vous voyez un
groupe de bleu rouge
et vous voyez en fait ils sont devant la
caserne ils sont 5 6 est-ce qu'on va
faire et ils sont en train de parler
avec des gardiens alors vous qui
peut pas parler à Pierre-Alain bon alors
ils savent pas qu'on leur chie dessus
depuis qu'on est parti
de contre rien
on a juste évité de dire que on était
avec eux mais on n'a jamais dit qu'on
était plutôt contre par exemple au maire
de
Lara oui mais c'est simplement pour
avancer
alors là je me compte vers Lucie je lui
dis vous connaissez les Aigles rouges
ici
oui c'est quoi votre avis
par la force et la terreur quoi et
amaryllis ils ont une influence
quelconque non d'accord donc si on
s'approche d'eux ils peuvent rien nous
faire
si vous avez des problèmes avec eux et
vous vous en avez
non donc ce qu'on va faire c'est on va
les éviter et si on allait juste
rentrer par une fenêtre des toilettes de
l'autre côté sans se faire voir parler
alors il se trouve qu'il y a une
boutique de vêtements à côté de la
caserne d'accord je vais pour acheter un
costume si vous voulez
j'achète un costume
de pompier
non il vous il faudrait mieux que ce
soit vous parce que
ils ont l'air de préférer les bonnes
femmes
je sais pas il faut il faut il faut
cacher la start-up là il faut
je suis comme tout un chacun
une tenue
de pas de déminage mais
écoutez j'ai un sarouel je peux rester
comme ça en haut je mets le cervelle en
bas
ça va peut-être une perruque est-ce
qu'il y a des perruques dans ce magasin
il y a quoi dans le magasin et si on
vous rajoute
foulard vous passez pour une babe tu vas
pouvoir acheter un foulard du coup dans
le magasin oui
tu veux un fleur de quelle couleur
je vous laisse choisir rouge est-ce que
rouge c'est une bonne idée est-ce que ça
peut attirer l'attention
rouge mais un peu éteint alors Bordeaux
Bordeaux
est-ce que vous prenez l'ancienne
monnaie
pas de
vous aimez les pieds de biche
est-ce que on pourrait faire un échange
non non est-ce que un badge du
générateur si vous intéresse vraiment
par contre là il faut plus que le
foulard est quelques iris non qu'est-ce
qu'on va en fait
ça vous intéresse
bon vous avez quoi avec on essaie de
faire un déguisement pour le carnaval
c'est quoi le carnaval c'est le nom
qu'on donne à une fête c'est un truc
familial on ne se déguise quoi on met
des tenues qui ne nous correspondent pas
en fait pour essayer de changer
d'identité et donc vous voulez vous
déguiser madame on cherche un costume
pour Madame d'accord est-ce que vous
avez suggestion on a déjà un sarouel on
s'est dit le foulard peut-être un
t-shirt tie and dye
puis vous auriez ça peut-être sur de
toutes les couleurs vous voulez dire oui
voilà oui oui je peux vous faire ça donc
le t-shirt et le foulard contre la
torche je pense que là il manque encore
quelque chose
bon la monnaie avec des torches non plus
bon mais juste les recharges des torches
ça vous intéresse pas non mais là on a
trop on a trop
on arrive dans le magasin
contre le foulard le t-shirt et 20 lisse
et on est quitte
non je peux pas me permettre de vous
donner de l'argent bon allez juste à
tort je donne la torche ok full art
de luxe le chat
et vous avez gagné un foulard et un
t-shirt
et vous rentrez dans la caverne
j'ai perdu mon crayon mais moi je pleure
un peu
là j'étais en train de sauver le monde
on était bien parti pour être chez nous
ce soir
OK et je prends une démarche de babos
aussi genre
de caserne
il y a les soldats des aigles rouges qui
sont devant il y avait les gardiennes
qui sont les gardes de la ville
moi je suis pas là
c'est quoi le plan c'est alors en amont
là elle se rappelle la flashback où on
discutait il faut
chercher des renseignements sur le clan
du sablier et sur Lucie c'est ça le but
c'était pas d'acheter une tie and dye
des renseignements sur Lucie est-ce que
je peux avoir le chien pour faire
vraiment la babosse jusqu'au bout
[Rires]
bien sûr voilà
je viens pour le la Réunion là vous
savez de 16h
on a dit si si on a parlé à enfin
[Rires]
[Musique]
au niveau de la cabine abandonnée là qui
nous a dit yo
je vois de loin
on boit un petit thé et puis on
discutera à chiffon quoi
alors me voici
où est votre thé
toute façon là on est occupé
à la même chose que vous ça tombe bien
pour vous
oui bien sûr c'est à propos de quoi
pas depuis 20 minutes
non non
les négociations
vous faites partie de des personnes je
fais partie
peut-être une bienfaitrice de Marylis
exactement d'accord j'ai pas encore
entendu parler de vous mais du coup
voilà et ben c'est exactement
ça discute
il y en a qui commence à te
regarder quand même
c'est qui elle
du coup il y a une gardienne qui dit par
mois c'est Barbara une bienfaitrice de
notre village elle a la tenue
[Musique]
à participer à la discussion
et il commence à regarder et tu as
l'impression qu'ils y croient pas une
seconde
il y a rien de bien intéressant on va
prendre cette discussion
il faut se renseigner sur Lucie
je me souviens peut-être le clan du
sablier
et dans la négociation là est-ce que
est-ce que l'un de vous qu'est-ce qu'on
fait pour Lucie
je sais pas si vous avez entendu parler
d'une certaine
[Musique]
partie ça vous dit quelque chose
vous connaissez si je porte
et vous
me disais bien que vous ressemblez à
quelqu'un flashback
et là je le regarde fixement dans les
yeux et je pars doucement en moonwoo
et aussi surtout ne parlez pas de
chicheportif mais comment je suis
maintenant moi aussi je m'en sers
dans un nuage de matière noire
des aigles rouges et les gardiennes les
arêtes et
disent NON NON approchez pas d'une
bienfaitrice du village sans
autorisation est-ce que il y a une
gardienne qui se calme il te fixe tous
de loin pendant que tu t'éloignes mais
je m’éloigne en faisant
surtout qu'il faut que je remonte la
colline en Monoa classification et
est-ce qu'il y aurait par hasard une
gardienne qui serait un peu plus proche
de moi qui je pourrais encore un peu
parler tu veux rester où tu veux partir
je peux faire du sport
[Musique]
désolé j'ai fait ce que j'ai eu des
informations sur pas grand chose à vrai
dire d'accord c'était pas très
intéressant
voilà à vous
et ben du coup
[Musique]
là nous on est avec Lucie qui a vu une
débandade
supériorité sur le groupe elle voit bien
enfin bon enfin là je suis dit ouais
Lucie bon voilà vous voyez bien ce que
vous voyez je vous assure il y a des
fois il va le coup d'accord
[Applaudissements]
elle faut lui parler de de Flappy et de
une génie dans un laboratoire mais alors
en dehors c'est un crapaud
c'est
incroyable et en même temps je donne un
petit coup de coude à Fredo en disant
ils ont cru que j'étais clean
je la regarde
bon on y va vous partez du coup donc
vous arrivez sur un endroit où il y a
pas mal de véhicules qui sont arrêtés
en fait c'est un peu en périphérie
vous amène elle vous fait rentrer dans
un véhicule vous dit bon bah voilà bon
on y va du coup on parfois élixir oui
donc je suppose qu'on va directement au
laboratoire vous voulez pas parler à
Beaulieu de ce que j'ai compris bah si
on peut l'éviter pour l'instant si on
peut partir direct
[Musique]
vous faites le trajet ça vous prend une
bonne heure notre trajet en voiture et
vous au bout d'un moment vous commencez
à reconnaître un peu le chemin que vous
aviez suivi lors de l'épisode 1 quand
vous étiez allé à pied pour accéder aux
galeries souterraines
pas longtemps après du coup Lucie
s'arrête
vous descendez du véhicule dit bon ben
laboratoire est juste à côté donc autant
qu'on passe par ce côté comme ça on est
sûr d'éviter avec le rouge ça marche
Lucie vous entrez dans le laboratoire
dans le secteur
c'est bien on est de retour
est-ce que
vous voulez directement les voir Gaston
vous voulez faire quelque chose avant
ce qu'on va voir l'autre tarte là
on va voir Céline d'accord bon vous
cherchez un peu Céline vous finissez par
la croisée vous dit ah vous êtes déjà de
retour
à Gaïa je peux pas vous en dire plus
mais sachez que cela s'est bien passé
mais ça a un rapport avec Hélène ou
non
de rien vous n'avez rien
on aurait pu mentir quoi on aurait pu
dire ouais non en fait pas du tout
mais bon dommage
qui s'illumine dans sourire quand même
et continue son chemin elle nous donne
sa bague non
on peut pas la dérober
quelque chose en retour
je lui dis pas
non non elle me dit vous voulez quelque
chose que non mais non
je sais pas trop ce que je peux vous
offrir
je sais pas vous avez quoi si vous avez
besoin de moi et que vous passez par
Gaïa
j'aurais juste à vous rendre n'importe
quel service une petite question
peut-être ça vous parle un peu
un clan des sabliers ou absolument une
Lucie non les gens savent pas grand
chose
[Musique]
très bien alors merci Céline je pense
que c'est le moment d'aller voir Gaston
non
on va voir Gaston
la salle à 4S du coup ah à 4S
oui mais je pense pas que vous allez
revenir si tôt
au bout d'une semaine ça fait trois
jours c'est pas prêt là
d'après les calculs de Gaston dans 4
jours minimum oui mais vous inquiétez on
a trouvé quelque chose sur le chemin qui
pourrait l'intéresser c'est pour ça on
est venu il y a cette dame voilà Lucie
Lucie là qui pense pouvoir vous aider
d'accord ce qu'elle nous a dit écoutez
je pense que ça ça coûte rien d'écouter
ce qu'elle a à dire je pense que ça
coûterait du coup tu feras pas la porte
au bout de 5 minutes il y a Gaston qui
ouvre
bonjour
on a fait une rencontre sur le chemin
vous allez
accélérer le processus
et je sais comment retourner dans le
passé du coup question bizarre quand
même et vous voyez les deux qui
s'isolent un peu et qui commencent à
discuter et Gaston qui a l'air comme un
fou et qui fait des réglages à tout de
suite c'est cool
c'est un moment où Lucie n'est pas à
côté de Pierre je précise qu'est-ce qui
s'est passé
un délire vite ce qui s'est passé c'est
qu'en fait
Lucie a pour but tout simplement de nous
revoyer dans le présent mais c'est juste
que
comment dire
voilà enfin elle est sympa quoi c'est
tout mais elle nous aime pas non je vous
aime pas en fait elle avait peur pour
moi au début elle s'est dit ah mais
c'est qui ces gens-là franchement
vous êtes arrivés avec nous
d'avoir peur de nous mais non mais c'est
les gens qui sont créatifs comme ça
enfin je veux dire tu vis dans le noir
tout le temps comme ça les gens ils
développent des peurs je pense que c'est
normal est-ce que de toute façon là elle
est en train de nous aider elle va nous
aider à retrouver dans le présent est-ce
qu'elle va pas vous faire partir vous et
puis nous elle va nous laisser là
après elle aurait pu vous laisser dans
le bon après qu'est-ce qu'on pourrait
faire pour l'acheter pour l'acheter quoi
elle va juste expliquer à Gaston Gaston
il va nous renvoyé mais qu'est-ce
qu'elle cherche
pourquoi elle nous aide bah c'est tout
simplement de la famille quoi
et puis c'est pour l'entraide familial
et puis peut-être c'est elle va venir
visiter le présent quoi je comprends pas
pourquoi c'est le labo souterrain alors
qu'elle travaille sur la même chose que
Gaston
pourquoi elle se cache Gaston il se
cache pas
et moi je vous dis est-ce que vous
connaissez quelqu'un qui peut vous
ramener dans le présent
il m'a pas l'air
fiable à 100% Lucile elle je l'ai vu de
mes yeux vu
elle est venue elle m'a dit salut vous
avez vu une espèce de boule lumineuse là
qui fait partie d'une institution qui
travaille dans un cadre particulier
qui terrorise les gens non il fait
partie d'un d'une institution
scientifique notable à horizon
excusez-moi mais je le fais poulet tiens
ce que oui peut-être d'une organisation
para-terroriste
qui martyrise la population autochtone
occupé mais excusez-moi mais votre babos
là qui qui travaille sous sa montée
qui maltraite ses citoyens ils sont pas
mal traités regardez Céline là elle
était contente tout à l'heure enfin
Amélie
elle travaille alors franchement les
scientifiques qui travaillent tout seul
dans laboratoire souterrain j'en ai
jamais entendu du mal personnellement
c'est un général qui font les
découvertes que on veut pas nous dire
les scientifiques tout seul dans des
souterrains c'est pas les grosses
institutions là qui ça c'est ça c'est
les balivernes enfin on va pas commencer
à croire ces gens là c'est sur l'uberlu
qui sortent de nulle part enfin Gloria
ce que vous en dites
Gloria je pense qu'elle va rentrer chez
elle non mais moi je
veux essayer ce qui est déjà en place
donc si cette Lucie a une solution qu'on
peut essayer
comme vous voulez mais moi
passer pour des vrais scientifiques
vous avez envie de changer le monde du
spolium et tout ça et de vaut mieux être
Joséphine moi c'est sûr un je l'ai vaut
deux tu l'auras et là on a un avoir de
transfert dans le passé je suis
extrêmement pas clair c'est passé un
certain moment quand j'ai parcouru des
gens là au bout d'un moment moi ça me
casse les couilles
si vous voulez
moi vous m'avez convaincu au techno
autoritarisme c'est vrai que
il y a beaucoup de syllabes pour vous
là en plus regardez là les deux là
ez j'ai réussi
j'ai pu créer une crèche dans
l'espace-temps qui m'a permis de voir le
passé de temps d'un instant oui bon
c'est bon on l'a vu autant on l'a
entendu votre lettre
non je pense que on a tout à gagner à
aller avec Lucie Gaston qui s'exclame
d'un coup qui dit mais c'est du génie
du génie ça c'est ma descendance ça bon
regarde qu'est-ce qui se passe et il
s'approche de vous il vous dit bon ben
je pense que c'est prêt
[Musique]
comment est-ce qu'on pourrait être sûr
que ça marche avant de le tester sur
nous parce que bon
je veux dire Lucie
tous en même temps alors
est-ce qu'on pourra avoir une preuve que
ça a marché on fait hallucie elle
t'explique que elle a déjà fait mais
comment ça marche on est tous dans une
pièce et on se rend on voyage tous
ensemble comme on est arrivé c'est la
même chose
dans laquelle vous vous étiez arrivés et
vous vous retrouvez dans la salle à 4S
c'est le processus inverse d'accord donc
on est tous ah oui on va retrouver des
boules d'énergie qui nous touchent et
tout
ok ok donc on est tous dans la même
pièce en même temps
vous êtes prêt ah est-ce qu'on peut
prendre juste quelques petits trucs
quelques petits souvenirs
justement qu'est-ce que vous gardez sur
vous et qu'est-ce que vous voulez c'est
dans le futur
dans les affaires que vous avez moi j'ai
rien est-ce qu'on a la recette du
Spadium
normalement
on a plus la
capeo
les maladies je fais ta gueule je vous
donnerai la recette quand on sera arrivé
là-bas ne vous inquiétez pas ça marche
super non
je garde Google est-ce que tu gardes ta
torche
[Musique]
pour préparer le futur
mais de toute façon vous inquiétez pas
je mets pas beaucoup
des torches
en fait c'est plus là qu'est-ce que vous
cachez concrètement
il faudrait un truc qui montre que c'est
pas une bonne chose de spoiler
il faudrait une
ça se teste ça de quoi
écouter le Spadium ça brûle ça fait du
Parnal
et on le teste quoi selon une règle et
oui mais si ta société elle est pas
prête à te croire
c'est de la science
du futur et on va créer un paradoxe
qu'elle pourrait faire elle connaît tout
ce qui s'est passé
ça va perturber la croissance
un progéniture
déjà un chien c'est un peu dangereux je
trouve mais alors un humain
sans casser des œufs mais on a on a la
recette et on a une piste de pourquoi ça
fout la merde on va voir les
scientifiques on leur dit voilà ça vous
faites gaffe parce que et là il y a big
spolium
les gens en milieu
on y va on y va
je sais pas ce que je voulais dire le
jardin
on peut pas c'est pas possible
je suis pas sûr ça
va rester dans les annales du monde
super oh là là
voilà super vous allez vous placer dans
la cuve du coup tous les deux oui nous
on y va on s'agrippe
en fait non là je parle à Lucie
dans le micro il faut lui parler à Lucie
plus dans le micro là
venez en secret rester dans la salle
cachez-vous par là
une fois que vous serez là-bas ils sont
devant le frère
complètement
il y a des meubles dans la cuve
quand on est venu vous êtes arrivés si
vous êtes sortis
est-ce qu'on peut pas demander à Gaston
qui nous je sais pas il nous donne des
petites indications sur ce cette machine
enfin ce truc oui il faut on a pas on a
pas écouté Gaston Gaston comment vous
avez réussi à
débloquer votre votre prototype
en gros truc tu comprends rien d'accord
super en fait c'était la clé de vous de
machin et tout donc en fait j'avais pas
compris que ça cette théorie ça marchait
pas dans ce cas là dans ce cas là mais
ça marchait dans l'autre sens et du coup
bah Lucie elle m'a expliqué comment
faire du coup pour déséquilibrer le
système machin je sais pas quoi
merci Gaston est-ce que vous voulez pas
qu'on qu'on amène un document dans le
passé qui pourrait être transmis en
faisant attention à ce qu'il soit bien
conservé
et qui vous éviterait bah je sais pas
qu'est-ce que
OK
non mais très bien je propose
faire quoi une petite preuve que le
monde détends ruines il y a des photos
si vous allez horizon vous pouvez en
trouver
c'est à dire qu'on est un peu pressé là
parce que là on va se faire choper par
des aigles rouges vont nous mettre en
prison
prenez une photo avec votre montre
Lucie se met dans la cuve
elle vient ouais
en fait alors non on vote démocratie
on va pas ramener quelqu'un du futur
avec nous c'est pas possible
je parle à Gaston
je sais pas pourquoi pas mais vous
imaginez le paradoxe que ça va créer par
quoi
on a déjà créé un paradoxe
m'a expliqué c'est qu'elle vient du
passé aussi et qu'elle s'est transportée
dans le futur et qu'elle était en train
d'essayer de reconstruire
la rencontrer ici nous a jamais dit ça
oui c'est ce qu'elle m'a dit vous l'avez
rencontré dans son laboratoire où elle a
essayé de faire une machine pour rentrer
chez elle alors non non
de Pierre Alain
et qu'elle essaie de l'aider à rentrer
chez lui
il y a Lucie elle s'énerve elle dit
vous pouvez pas tenir vosbiennes
c'est quoi ces conneries pierrelay là
c'est les pires je suis désolé Lucie
est-ce que je peux lui en coller une
Lucie
pour 18 sur 60 et il y a Fredo qui te
met une énorme tarte tu perds un point
de vue
ça va pas le bien là
et moi je lui fais la cloche
échec critique bon c'est pas comme ça
on peut pas ramener vous imaginez ce
qu'elle pourrait faire avec tout ce
qu'elle sait c'est grâce à elle que vous
pouvez rentrer quand même oui d'accord
et ben pour ça merci bien madame ça il y
a pas de souci mais imaginez elle baise
avec son arrière-grand-père oh là là je
suis cru mais bon un moment donné quoi
c'est ça les paradoxes
la littérature française
de machin mais elle a jamais dit que
c'était la descente de machin
et elle de son côté elle m'a ramené une
théorie qui fonctionne complètement et
qui résout mon équation je pense qu'elle
a passé si elle était de notre époque
elle aurait les connaissances pour faire
du voyage dans le temps mais je n'en
sais rien mais tout le monde
pour faire du voyage dans le temps c'est
pas déconnant qu'elle c'est des voyages
et dans le temps
elle va venir elle va revenir dans le
temps par elle-même en fait elle a pas
besoin de nous maintenant a priori et
pourquoi elle va rentrer avec nous
il faut pas laisser les gens voyager
dans le temps là déjà il faut arrêter
vos conneries de voyage longtemps vous
nous avez déjà kidnappé c'était la
première erreur il faut arrêter
maintenant je vous renvoie pas chez vous
si parce qu'on essaie de réparer quand
on fait les erreurs Gaston et puis on
vous a bien rendu service des bêtises
oui d'accord j'essaie de réparer oui
mais pas avec elle et donc elle elle
laissait pas de réparer non mais elle
c'est une nouvelle erreur Gaston là vous
mettez dans un merdier sauf que nous on
était con comme des quilles donc ça on
vous renvoie dans le passé mais elle on
la renvoie pas chez elle pourquoi elle
vient pas du passé Gaston vous en savez
mais parce que nous à notre époque
on est on pouvait pas voyager dans le
temps enfin je veux dire c'était qu'elle
l'a fait vous avez vu
est-ce que est-ce
c'est une connerie pourquoi mais parce
que elle ne vient pas de notre époque je
sais pas comment vous le prouvez enfin
je sais pas vous avez pas changé quoi ça
va créer des paradoxes
de science-fiction
de paradoxe
donc vous avez peut-être le changer le
monde aussi
en plus franchement en fait je vois pas
la différence entre
personne
votre objectif c'était c'était de nous
renvoyer et que on puisse éventuellement
vous aider un peu à éviter
nous on peut arrêter la catastrophe on
accroche
d'accord
vraiment je me penche vers lui je lui ai
dit la Lucie là on ne sait pas de c'est
pas d'où elle vient c'est pas ce qu'elle
peut faire action elle pourrait ruiner
nos efforts répondre au loin elle dit je
viens de 2023 et j'ai aucun problème
avec le fait qu'on arrête de se poser de
produire du Spadium moi je trouve c'est
mon horrible
mais voilà elle a gagné argument je suis
désolé monsieur mais vous venez de
perdre votre shoot argumentaire
Gaston
BIM me up
Scotty
envoie-moi dans le dans le passé
Gaston mais la bonne année
on rigole pas parce qu'on est sans on
meurt
c'est pas un truc j'imagine 2000 en 2017
et on se revoit à nous oh là là est-ce
que vous avez bien une photo du
Protocole des Sages de Sion dans l'autre
de
protocole petit papa moi j'ai tous mes
papiers bien rangé tu as une photo
j'ai jamais réussi à le lire alors
du coup vu qu'il y avait beaucoup de
difficultés sur cette discussion de
est-ce qu'on renvoie Lucie dans le passé
ou pas ils ont fait un sondage dans le
chat pour savoir est-ce que Lucie
retourne dans le passé ou pas le chat a
dit que oui Lucie va dans le passé ah de
toute façon moi j'étais c'est bon
j'étais bougon là
donc vous rentrez tous les cinq dans la
cuve on a un peu serré là
il faut commencer à entendre du bruit
oh non votre vision se déforme votre
corps ne vous répond plus
des flashs de lumière se font de plus en
plus rapide bien vous ayez déjà vécu
cette expérience vous êtes bien
conscient que votre corps ne s'y
habituera sûrement jamais une fois que
vous une fois de plus vous êtes pris de
nausées mais cette fois vous n'avez pas
peur vous êtes même rassuré les flashs
se mettent à ralentir vous reprenez
doucement vos esprits tous allongés au
sol de la salle de stockage à 4S que
vous ne connaissez baigné d'une Lure
rouge à peine le temps de vous redresser
qu'un bruit de sonnette se fait entendre
l'éclairage revient à la normale les
portes de la salle se déverrouille avant
de s'ouvrir sur les couloirs du complexe
Elixia
c'est trop bien on y retourne
mais du coup oui c'est vrai qu'on est
encore plus avec nous
là vous êtes donc tous dans la salle il
y a également bouga et Lucie vous avez
quelques appareils avec vous que vous
avez transporté
donc maintenant on va faire un petit un
petit prologue à toute l'histoire pour
savoir un peu qu'est-ce que deviennent
vos personnages après ces aventures donc
la première chose que je vais vous
demander c'est vos relations à vous
quatre qu'est-ce que ça va devenir ce
que vous connaissez pas l'origine
on peut décider
à la date de disparition voilà
juste une rencontre du portable à chaque
fois
on s'est écrit un peu des textos le
lendemain mais après
moi ma réponse elle va dépendre de
ce que je fais ce que eux ils vont faire
en fait
tu peux dire genre à partir de demain là
comment tu vois les autres parce que toi
tu vas rentrer chez toi tu vois donc
soit tu peux complètement reprendre ton
train de vie et tu leur reparleras
jamais non mais est-ce que tu veux faire
oui mais ça on va voir après mais
d'abord
oublier non en fait j'ai presque envie
de surveiller Lucie tu vois du coup
d'accord
les autres c'est bon cette époque bah ça
va quoi genre je leur tiens pas
d'animosité en tout cas vous êtes tous
potes en gros où il y a des gens qui
veulent pas s'entendre
pour pour relation commerciale voilà
pour développer le spolium c'est vrai
que moi je veux relancer mon chantier le
plus vite possible donc je voudrais bien
que la CCI arrête avec ces travaux
géothermie elle s'en fout un peu
d'accord parce que
tu vois
très vite se dégrader
et moi mais chacun de vos chantiers
mais pas un problème pas un problème
parce que là ce qu'on va devenir c'est
que la CCI et la nouvelle entreprise
enfin j'imagine non Flappy la peau voilà
flapo devient un financeur mais
incroyable de l'archéologie du projet
alors là les fouilles c'est super
allez-y comme ça et venez on va faire
une conférence presse bientôt pour
parler de à quel point l'archéologie
c'est génial et à quel point la CCI vos
logos voilà c'est ça génial
aussi dans la vie dans la recherche pour
trouver un emploi tout ça ou même fort
je vais faire un petit tour de table
rapidement Gloria ton site de fou tu le
reprends ou tu l'arrêtes
bah non je le je l'arrête et je vais
prospecter ailleurs d'accord parce que
j'ai vu ce que c'était
alors je dirais que j'ai pas assez de
sous pour continuer la
la fouille
et j'aimerais bien aller moi je veux
continuer de
je sais pas je pense que je vais faire
un musée sur l'archéologie du futur
d'accord voilà j'aligne les millions
horizon et à fond génial avec la musique
c'est donc il y a un musée en ton nom
sur l'archéologie futur qui va avoir le
jour à horizon je vois l'ouverture de la
banderole là
le signe de fouille le site de fouille
est abandonné donc tu arrêtes de te
battre là-dessus donc au final le
chantier de centre de centrale reprend
comme c'était prévu à l'origine t'as
même pas eu besoin de te battre pour ça
finalement la centrale sera construite à
cet endroit
peut-être augmenter un petit peu la
sécurité du générateur
comme ça
et la secte de la Lune Noire du coup ne
pourra pas prendre place ces lieux
intuition
donc tu évites la création d'une secte
plus tard ah là là là là
est-ce que tu vas faire ton troisième
mandat là tu étais en cours de ton
deuxième mandat tu étais au début de ton
deuxième moment est-ce que tu vas à la
fin ton deuxième vendeur aller sur ton
troisième ou alors tu pars à ta retraite
et tu essaies de vivre des beaux jours
tranquillement je pense que donc je vais
pour le troisième mandat mais sauf que
pendant le pain avoir ce que va faire
églantine mais je pense qu'on a vraiment
une bonne boîte à créer là on a un truc
là enfin je veux dire
une petite idée je pense qu'il y a quand
même quelque chose quoi donc
c'est ça donc du coup tu continues sur
ton troisième mandat mais je l'arrête
dès que dès que ça enfin là c'est juste
pour faire pour faciliter les prêts
enfin voilà que ça facilite les choses
quoi pour huiler un peu le système voilà
je suis clairement lubrifiant économique
peut-être oublié une information que tu
as eu lors de l'épisode 2 mais tu
finiras par perdre la vie lors de ton
troisième mandat
oui mais je vais sans doute pas le faire
en fait en 2030
oui en 2030 j'abandonne le mot mais je
suis super riche les gens riches ne
meurent pas mais du coup il y aura une
rue d'horizon qui portera pas géniale
oui non moi je visais la domination
mondiale ok d'accord
du coup Lucie prendra le relais super
super
[Musique]
qu'est-ce que tu fais alors en tant que
tu es actuellement concierge est-ce que
tu continues à vivre en tant que
concierge
oui mais non c'est à dire que je j'y
reste un temps parce que tout de suite
je vais voir les scientifiques que je
connais
parce que bon tu es concierge depuis
autant de temps que moi il revient tu
voilà tu connais déjà et je leur
explique quoi je leur dis là
vous êtes en train de travailler sur une
connerie
enfin non ils sont pas en train de
travailler dessus je dis il y a une
entreprise là qui est en train de se
monter la Flappy
Flappy flapo ils sont bref ça va
peut-être changer de nom
ils vont et donc j'explique je dis voilà
ils vont bosser sur le spolium il faut
absolument pas les laisser faire et donc
j'explique parce que ça va créer du parc
du panoral et ça va faire une réaction
de dandaulte et l'atmosphère il va être
détruit et j'ai une photo avec moi de
action de landaulte oui de London j'ai
un autre truc que je ferai mais d'abord
dis-moi ce qui se passe
combien de temps dans Alicia non mais
pas longtemps genre j'ai une ou deux
semaines genre juste plus je leur dis ça
et ensuite je deviens lanceur d'alerte
je crée un blog d'accord sur lequel un
blog et une page Facebook sur lequel
j'allaise un truc n'existe pas
se développer attention Flappy ils vont
détruire l'atmosphère avec le panoral
après je suis concierge donc c'est pas
très bien rédigé c'est pas ça fait très
que théorie du complot voilà ça c'est
très complot
tu vois cette photo que j'ai récupéré
c'est c'est le truc et j'essaie il y a
des gens qui te suivent quand même et
qui vont ton truc mais voilà c'est aux
yeux des grands publics c'est vraiment
une théorie du complot qui a vu le jour
ouais mais j'ai je l'ai expliqué aux
scientifique quand même délicat avant de
partir
[Musique]
protocole petit mais du coup le
protocole petit ne verra pas le jour
tout de suite parce que du coup c'était
vraiment ta mort qui avait fait beaucoup
de bruit en fait et qui avait ralenti
énormément les recherches sur le Spadium
mais vu qu'il y a eu un accident qui n'a
pas fait de victime au final on s'est
juste dit bon je suis en mais c'est pas
grave c'est que du dégât matériel du
coup ça s'est développé de fou et au
final les accidents sont les croissant
avec le temps d'un matin mais un
équivalent du protocole petit a fini par
être développé
quand ils ont commencé à le faire ils
ont pas testé ma théorie même si j'étais
un illuminé genre Didier Raoult on a
quand même testé que l'hydroxycloorking
[Musique]
le spolium c'est quand même développé à
un moment donné oui de ça d'accord oui
mais voilà je reviens sur toi ton truc
après du coup il y a eu beaucoup
d'accident parce que du coup tu vas
éviter ta mort du coup il y a plus de
victimes que ça oh bah super mais au
final ça a permis de ralentir en fait la
production spolium parce que du coup ça
a été jugé extrêmement dangereux
et en plus de tes lancements d'alerte
qui ont été testés par des scientifiques
et ça a essayé d'être ralenti le plus
possible donc le spodium ça reste
quelque chose qui est utilisé beaucoup
moins donc c'est très probable que vous
finissiez par éviter la catastrophe
et bouga qu'est-ce qui est devenu son
chien très grave ce que tu veux
toi
tu restes sur la découverte de pétrole
où tu rebrandes
[Musique]
c'était voulu
inscrivez-vous sur le site
il faut réserver le juste
ma tête
non bah du coup pour s'entreprise flapi
ton entreprise flapo du coup elle a été
lancée avec
Pierre-Alain ça marche bien
les profits
du coup par contre donc ce qui était sur
la découverte de pétrole il y a
l'entreprise tatol qui vient
racheter à 400 €
400000 €
franchement j'ai appris des meilleurs
pour essayer de négocier et du coup je
leur dis c'est 2 millions ou rien en
fait quel hommage c'est vraiment une
entreprise qui va partir en mode
exponentiel vous voyez les profits tout
ça vous le savez comme moi on a trouvé
un super gisement on va continuer à
retrouver d'autres vraiment vous pouvez
me faire confiance c'est un peu comme si
j'avais une boule de cristal pour voir
dans l'avenir c'est un bon
investissement donc 2 millions ou rien
c'est rien comme tu veux mais allez-y
hein
attends à quel moment il me demande ça
est-ce que c'est avant 2030
on y va domination mondiale ah ouais
tu te rends compte que Flappy c'est du
bullshit alors
[Musique]
on a trouvé par hasard on a trouvé par
hasard un gisement mais en fait il y a
rien depuis le début d'accords
et flapo du coup se porte bien oui par
contre mais du coup
flapo est au courant qu'il y a un
protocole petit et tout ça et donc en
fait il y a pas d'accident de spolium et
en fait ça va super vite et tout le
monde est dans le noir dans 10 ans quoi
vu qu'il y a beaucoup d'accidents sur
les autres entreprises ah oui vous ça se
développe mieux mais est-ce que vous
voulez faire attention quand même à ce
truc de paranormal et trouver une
solution et à mettre un peu de recherche
sur ce sujet ou vous vous en foutez
complètement moi je dirais bien oui mais
factuellement
[Musique]
dans les dans les lampes là dans
l'inverse et ils étaient contents
franchement non le tout c'est bien
d'investir dans du
dans ouais dans du verre
à l'inverse du pardon à l'inverse de
l'obscurité tu vois on dit ah non nous
on finance la lumière on finance la
lumière
on fait du greenwashing pour les femmes
voilà tout va bien dans le meilleur des
mondes
on parle pas de panoral c'est un mot
interdit chez nous
oui ça se développe mais moi je voulais
venir vous embêter un peu parce que ça
abîme les peintures rupestres
vous n'avez rien
si vous voulez
sur mon blog
oui et non
elle fait les plateaux et quand on lui
dit vous êtes d'accord avec une petite
écoutez c'est pas c'est pas ce que j'ai
dit
avec le retour est difficile quand même
bon donc du coup en gros vous arrivez à
freiner la production de spolium mondial
eux ils créent
ça comme étant du spolium propre qui ne
sort pas du Père Noël sauf le spawium
c'est tellement pratique que au final ça
se développe surtout si c'est propre
sauf qu'en fait il mentent ils sont en
train d'expliquer il me semble comme
Edwards donc malheureusement les
particules noirs finiront par arriver
tout est la faute du capitalisme voilà
et Lucie
juste elle a rien fait de mal elle a
noyé personne
Pierre-Alain en fait tous les choix de
Pierre Alain sont régis par ce que ça va
changer dans le futur
ah grâce à Lucie oui mais du coup tu te
dis Pierre Alain est un génie parce
qu'il fait que des bons choix et à
chaque fois qu'il en fait un mauvais il
revient dessus le lendemain
[Musique]
on crée flapule travail
on a gagné on est devenu
comme ça
non c'est une question de rendre le
monde meilleur
pour vous
j'aimais bien
arrivé à se dire tiens j'ai accompli
quelque chose dans ma vie
comment tirer profil la situation
moi je suis mort à faire des vidéos
Youtube
je pense que surtout tu peux vraiment
avoir ce truc là ou si tu sais à la base
que ton truc il est un petit peu moyen
j'ai vu que tu es rentré dedans et c'est
là-bas
je peux pas arrêter quoi maintenant tu
peux plus reculer quoi non est-ce que tu
vois en fait c'est même au bout de 50 et
nous on voit même plus le paranormal
machin là
le but c'est de d'aider les gens puis
même légalement aux premières
déclarations que tu as fait qui mentent
tu peux pas revenir dessus après enfin
c'est foutu quoi le paon c'est un truc
de blogueur oui complètement franchement
personne a prouvé que ça existait quoi
par exemple source si dans le chat si
jamais vous avez quelques questions
n'hésitez pas maintenant j'ai le chat
donc je vais pouvoir vous dire si jamais
vous avez posé juste avant j'avais pas
vu parce que j'ai pas historique donc
repose télé c'est quoi la réaction de
Landaul du groupe ça c'est un truc de
fou j'ai oublié de réviser tout à
l'heure parce que du coup on a mis du
temps à
monter le studio mais en gros je vais
expliquer de ce que j'ai compris c'est à
2 solutions chimiques donc liquide je
pense que dans l'air c'est pas possible
mais en gros je me suis dit ce serait
flippant si ça marchait dans l'air
tu mets mixes les deux qui ont la même
[Musique]
quantité des deux côtés c'est de je sais
plus ce que c'est les deux différents
mais si vous cherchez réaction de
Landaul sur Internet vous allez voir
plein de vidéos qui montrent ça c'est
mix les deux ça fait une réaction et du
coup c'est toujours translucide comme de
l'eau et en fait quand la réaction elle
est finie et qui a une une des molécules
qui qui arrête d'exister dans le dedans
ça change la réaction et ça devient
entièrement noir d'un coup mais en une
fraction de seconde
c'est effrayant regardez ce que vraiment
les expériences juste ils versent une
carafe comme ça et au bout d'un moment
bah juste tout vient noir
mais c'est quoi comme ça marche avec
enfin c'est quoi comme molécule
je sais plus mais c'est un truc super
basique du chlore du sodium des trucs
de réaction en fait une réaction c'est
un type de réaction ça s'appelle une une
horloge
[Musique]
je sais plus un truc je pense
c'est une réaction qui met du temps à se
faire et quand elle est finie ça fait un
truc d'un coup
voilà je me suis dit si le père Noël ça
fait ça donc petit à petit vous
embrassez l'atmosphère
et voilà mais du coup allez voir sur
internet c'est beaucoup plus visuel
vraiment j'ai quand j'ai vu ça j'étais
bluffé je me suis dit waouh mais a
priori c'est des solutions
là quelque part sur sur le truc
climatique avec les boucles de
rétroaction et de choses comme ça
c'était un peu le but évidemment
j'ai fait j'ai fait un jet de
perspicacité
si on veut régler le problème de du
climat on pourrait juste arrêter de
produire tout mais c'est pas possible
écoutez
bref
ah c'est mieux
oui on parlait de trucs scientifiques
justement enfin qu'est-ce que vous avez
relevé vous comme
truc scientifique dans ce ben ouais
parce que moi j'ai vu quelques trucs la
thermosynthèse j'ai plein
et ça ça m'a surpris au moins une plante
qui fait ça moi je m'étais dit bon il y
en a bien une quelque part dans un pays
qui fait juste avec la chaleur non ça
n'existe pas c'est tellement enfin le
délire des mitochondries et tout c'est
tellement ancestral ouais mais je me
suis dit il y a peut-être un moment où
il y en a une elle a pété un plomb
c'est que ce serait comme les
distinction plein de champignons tu vois
je pense hein
je suis tombé sur
un truc complètement différent
je vais vous le mettre dans le chat
d'ailleurs je vous mets un lien
[Musique]
non mais fin c'est pour moi ça n'a rien
à voir enfin le photon c'est une
particule la chaleur c'est pas partie
c'est pas corpusculaire tu vois c'est
chimique donc déjà c'est
enfin je sais pas non en fait la
photosynthèse c'est de la chimie aussi
mais ouais
pour moi c'est des c'est enfin je suis
pas sûr que mais après j'y connais rien
en fait pour moi c'est pas juste c'est
pas un petit changement dans une cellule
végétale qui va permettre ça c'est genre
une structure totalement différente des
organites dans la cellule totalement
différent pas tant que ça en fait il
faudrait des enzymes capables de
désassembler la chaleur en gros en gros
tu prendrais des molécules chaudes
tu es désassemblent tu chopes l'énergie
on lui refroidissant et du coup cette
énergie c'est pareil que l'énergie
puissant des photos claire quoi
je vois là je vois que la radioactivité
qu'il libère de la chaleur spontanément
tu vois enfin des atomes qui du coup
libèrent de la chaleur mais après je
suis je suis une quille en biologie
enfin moi aussi tout ce qui organique
j'y connais rien du coup si vous n'êtes
pas une quille et que ça vous intéresse
allez voir un peu ce qu'ils ont dit sur
ce truc là sur le truc que j'ai envoyé
moi j'ai trouvé ça très stylé même si
j'y comprenais pas les trois cœurs mais
je me suis dit waouh c'est joli
il y a ça il parle aussi du coup de j'ai
envie ils disent genre voilà le plus
simple parce que la thermosynthèse mais
en vrai si on veut partir un peu en
couille on peut partir sur de la
radioactivité des rayons gamma des
rayons infrarouges enfin de tout et
voilà ils ont mis à chaque fois genre
les réactions chimiques que ça devrait
faire du coup pour que ça fonctionne je
trouvais ça super stylé mais du coup
c'est vraiment trop poussé donc moi je
dis thermosynthèse
quelque chose qu'on peut évoquer aussi
je sais justement un peu tous ces trucs
là de comment gérer des
ces externalités négatives justement de
du panormal plus simple panoral panoral
les conséquences négatives les comment
s'appelle je suis désolé il est tard du
coup ton plannalités externalités
négatives c'est ce que tu avais dit
du coup ça veut dire que je sais
peut-être un petit peu de quoi je parle
du coup
conséquences négatives les choses
externes les paradoxes
en gros quand tu as un processus
économique comme la production de ou
l'utilisation de de spolium par exemple
qui a une conséquence tiers enfin tu
vois c'est par exemple tu as une usine
qui est sur un fleuve et elle produit
des chaises mais aussi du mercure dans
l'eau du coup l'externalité négative
c'est le mercure dans l'eau avec un
impact en fait économique sur tout un
pan de
tout ce qui est en dessous du fleuve
voilà donc c'est le bénéfice des chaises
tu vois mais tu as l'inconvénient du
mercure et on a tendance aujourd'hui à
faire exactement ce que nous on
cherchait à faire avec avec flapo c'est
à oublier la partie externalité négative
en disant non ça rentre pas dans notre
calcul économique c'est un peu de gens
notre système économique évalue
seulement les externalités c'est pas
c'est pas vraiment ça mais c'est il y a
un gros focus sur les externalités
positives sur les sur les la production
directe et pas sur les externalités
négatives et du coup c'est une manière
de voir la
les
la pollution en fait c'est de le
comprendre que une externalité négative
et du coup de se dire ok mais il y a un
calcul économique à faire dans chaque
production humaine de se dire on voit
très bien la production donc c'est la
production de chaise maintenant
regardons l'autre
production négative on va dire les
pollutions et ça peut être des
pollutions sonores ça peut être ça peut
vraiment être tout ce qui peut être
négatif et qu'on peut dire tiens on peut
essayer de chiffrer ça aussi et
d'essayer de faire un calcul économique
en voyant
est-ce que votre activité économique est
plus intéressante que les externalités
ou est-ce que qu'est-ce que le bilan
carbone c'est un peu ça
tu prends vraiment le truc
j'ai pas qu'est-ce qui montre comment
sauver la planète et que tu tournes
partout dans le voilà tu as pris 10 fois
l'avion ouais mais là tu vois c'est
justement c'est tu peux essayer de
d'évaluer ça se trouve une externalité
enfin
est-ce qu'il faut faire zéro film avec
la question ça te met en fait un calcul
économique des deux côtés tu vois plutôt
que de dire
on voit le positif mais on voit le
négatif mais on quand il vise pas le le
négatif donc il y a pas de d'euros
derrière le négatif là on pourrait dire
bah ok ça rapporte ça mais ça coûte ça
en pollution quoi donc ça c'est tout un
il y a tout un courant comme ça qui
essaye de
dire je suppose que les entreprises qui
font du Queen washing elle se concentre
plutôt sur
riduler les émissions dans leur
production mais toujours en ignorant
externalités négatives du coup après la
problématique des externalités négatives
c'est que tu peux choisir c'est
ultra dur de tout quantifier parce que
l'usine qui vers son mercure dans je
sais pas j'ai pris ça mais
qui déversent les pollutions dans un
fleuve elle peut dire ok ouais bah
qu'est-ce qui compte est-ce que c'est
juste
ah ouais la pollution ça abîme les
poissons et tu calcules que ça quoi tu
dis juste ah bah les pêcheurs ils ont un
ils ont des conséquences négatives et
donc du coup leur activité elle baisse
est-ce que tu calcules aussi ah oui mais
il y a des enfants qui souffrent du
mercure dans l'eau mais tu peux compter
aussi ah oui mais attends il y a des il
y a des oiseaux migrateurs qui enfin tu
vois en fait tu as toute une pyramide de
truc où tu peux en fait rapidement
arriver à l'infini tu vois c'est chaque
action humaine peut avoir une infinité
de dès que c'est négative et du coup
c'est
cette tension là et on le voit justement
sur les tous les trucs de projet
aujourd'hui quand on parle des grands
projets type les bassines ou les projets
là aujourd'hui
mais tous tous les projets en ce moment
en France ailleurs machin et à chaque
fois il y a des études d'impact et ces
études d'impact là une partie c'est de
voir qu'est-ce qu'on va
qu'est-ce qui va jarter avec ça quoi oui
mais d'essayer de ce projet là c'est
aussi critiquer parce qu'en fait c'est
des c'est pas des innovations c'est des
vieux trucs qu'il a des années 60
à quel point est-ce que tu pousses ces
analyses là à quel point est-ce que tu
fais rentrer ce
calcul économique en négatif tu vois ah
oui c'est c'est ce que des pays comme
justement le Pakistan réclament après
les inondations parce que c'est une
inondation directement lié au
à la crise climatique en fait les gros
pays pollueurs payés pour nos
réparations
[Musique]
c'est ça en fait les débats c'est que ça
c'est les débats quand tu as direct avec
des victimes qui se ressentent comme
victime tu vois mais tu as plein de
trucs en fait les victimes ils ont pas
de voix enfin c'est un oiseau migrateur
bah
il va pas te il va pas porter plainte
quoi donc c'est d'essayer de mettre un
prix pour tous ces trucs là après il t'a
plein de débats sur Oui mais en fait
mettre un prix c'est
ça marchera jamais quoi tant que tu
restes dans cette dynamique là tu
trouveras toujours un truc pour que ça
fasse 1 € de plus du côté bénéfique et
bon bah du coup on dégage tout quoi
voilà c'était ma petite mon petit point
que un petit peu long la petite question
dans le chat
il y a grand thème qui demande les
végétaux qui utilisent plus la
photosynthèse du coup il devrait
peut-être être blanc
c'est très probable j'avoue que je suis
pas très fort là-dedans mais je pense
que oui si j'utilise plus la
photosynthèse ils ont plus de raison
d'être vert
il devrait mourir en fait seul le truc
mais bon
synthèse de la place ah oui bah après on
peut imaginer enfin qui reste vert je
veux dire ils ont étage c'est un peu au
pif qui soit vert en fait genre non
c'est la faute
des molécules qui fonction sévère mais
je veux dire la thermosynthèse pourrait
faire du verre aussi faire du vert ou du
rouge ou moi je vote pour un pigment qui
au contraire capterait beaucoup la
chaleur donc s'il y a encore du soleil
même si il le voit plus à ce moment-là
on peut imaginer des plantes qui
seraient noir et comme ça s'absorbent à
fond les la chaleur et la console
pas aux couleurs des plantes sous l'eau
quoi
qui sont rouges vif rouge
après c'est une conséquence que ça oui
c'est une conséquence mais dans le monde
que tu as imaginé c'est juste qu'on voit
plus la lumière mais elle y est oui mais
du coup
on avait imaginé c'était une fréquence
d'onde en gros qui passe plus genre le
visite peut-être qu'en fait genre les
plantes seraient de couleur en dehors du
spectre visible en vrai
du coup pour nous ça semblerait noir ou
blanc parce qu'il y aurait pas de
couleur genre gris et en fait si on
regarde avec un filtre spécial je vois
que c'est peut-être
complètement ouf ok c'est juste que nous
on voit pas mais
ce genre de truc et l'autre question de
grand thème c'est qui les personnes avec
les sabliers un genre de brigade
temporelle
en gros c'était une brigade temporelle
belle rêve grand m au passage voilà une
brigade temporelle oui ah mais oui
assez d'épisodes pour pour ficeler ça
mais normalement ça allait être des gens
qui allaient essayer de vous empêcher de
changer l'avenir
mais du coup bon bah fallait bien couper
court mais ils ont ils ont changé
il faisait bien quoi
comment ils étaient au courant alors
vous avez quand même fait beaucoup de
bruit
[Musique]
merci de me reconnaître
la discrétion n'était pas du coup c'est
bizarre pour c'est bizarre que le mec
nous ait pris en photo et c'est tout si
vous voulez nous arrêter tu vois ouais
mais imagine bien que si c'est un groupe
qui entend parler de vous et qui se
disent waouh attend c'est dangereux ça
et qui commence à enquêter sur vous pour
savoir qui vous êtes vraiment juste
parce que pour l'instant c'est des
bruits de couloir genre tout seul en un
compte 4 juste se dire
on étudie un peu le truc qu'est-ce qu'on
va faire et c'est ça que j'allais amené
mais du coup en un épisode ce n'était
pas possible et du coup là là on avait
en fait aucun moyen de d'en apprendre
c'était juste pour vous dire vous saurez
face
on a forcé quand même hein
[Rires]
[Musique]
pourquoi il a une tête effrayante genre
c'est un demi-mousse trop
[Musique]
en fait il est venu avec une tête tout
accueillante et tout pour pas
que vous le soupçonniez de quoi que ce
soit ça a bien marché oui mais du coup
après en fait en vrai il a peur de vous
et même il vous le déteste parce qu'en
fait il est persuadé que vous allez le
tuer enfin détruire son monde en fait ça
c'est un peu un ninja le type j'essaie
de lui lancer un truc il a fait genre
parce que bon il y a aussi un moyen un
moment où moi à partir de l'épisode 3 je
savais qu'il allait falloir boucler les
trucs c'est à dire que si on avait fait
huit épisodes je serai certain moi je
t'aurais dit ok tu le cul et il y en
aurait eu un autre quoi non c'est quoi
les conséquences que tu as tué un mec
dans la rue d'un village à ton avis ah
non mais je l'aurais pas tué je l'aurais
assommé
[Musique]
j'ai pas ajouté très fort que les
conséquences elles allaient plutôt être
sur toi plus que sur leur groupe à eux
et grand thème qui dit je pensais que
Lucie était même leur chef
il y avait pas de lien entre les deux
mais je comprends le doute
et j'ai eu une autre question de Mister
game
c'est question à notre économiste y
a-t-il des entreprises qui sont vendues
des millions car reconnu comme
révolutionnaire pour le futur je suppose
que oui tout le temps
est-ce qu'il y en a qui était des
grosses arnaques en fait
il y en a tout le temps il y a même des
boîtes où tu as des gens qui sont
persuadés qui bossent pas dans des trucs
d'arnaque et en fait au dernier moment
ah bah non en fait c'était basé sur rien
enfin il y avait des trucs ou des choses
comme ça une grosse boîte tout le monde
enfin vraiment c'était des analystes qui
sont là oui super
super boîte investissez dedans tout ça
je sais plus en quelle année c'était je
crois que c'était
dans un magazine s'appelle socialter le
dernier numéro il est sur justement les
milliardaires ce genre de choses et donc
ici notamment toutes les entreprises qui
vendent à ces milliardaires des
solutions pour l'avenir donc
du futur des îlots
[Musique]
et c'est hyper intéressant comme comme
dossier c'est vrai qu'il y a toute enfin
plus aussi tu es dans une économie où tu
as des personnes riches individuelles
plus tu vas aussi dans une économie de
la démesure un petit peu aussi où il
suffit que ce soit la fantaisie d'une
personne pour que
mais c'est vraiment de l'arnaque à la
petite semaine quoi sauf avec des avec
des milliards quoi enfin c'est vraiment
le même principe et c'est un peu les
trucs de Ponzi enfin c'est
il n'y a rien de plus basique qu'un
Ponzi enfin de c'est quoi un Ponzi c'est
quand tu je te dis ah tiens si tu me
files de 1000 dans trois semaines je te
donne 1100 Bitcoin
non parce que après je dis ah tiens si
tu me filmes 1000 ah tiens si tu me
files et je dis ça à tout le monde mais
c'est
un schéma
c'est autre chose MLM c'est un système
de vente mais qui fait un peu mais c'est
un peu la même chose
en gros c'est à chaque endroit voilà en
fait tu tu gagnes du temps à la boule de
neige tu vois tu où tu rembourses avec
de l'argent que tu gagnes plus de gens
qui rentrent dans le système c'est fini
il y a plein de systèmes où ça marche
même avec des gens qui voilà sont riches
machin vraiment des gens tu sais où tu
dis ils doivent avoir une connaissance
financière ils ont les capacités d'avoir
des avocats des machins non il s'ennuie
mais ça ça marche quand même et plus tu
as de pouvoir dans des personnes plus tu
vois des trucs comme ça
impressionnants quoi enfin pas aussi
impressionnant de ton animal pardon
et comment tu fais pour valoriser une
entreprise une start-up
comment tu fais pour la valoriser ouais
genre tu as j'arrive en disant de 2
millions d'euros genre d'où ça sort en
fait c'est comment est-ce que toi
comment est-ce que toi tu penses que
enfin il y a plein de mécanismes
externalités
une valorisation ça peut être quelqu'un
veut t'acheter un certain montant tu
vois oui d'accord si quelqu'un t'achètes
à ce moment-là on sait que ça vaut ça
après tu as aussi combien de
de thunes a été mise dans ton truc et
puis tu as des analystes aussi qui vont
dire ah ça vaut ça parce que
c'est du c'est au doigt mouillé quoi tu
sais c'est ça le truc c'est tu sais
jamais vraiment combien un truc vaut là
aujourd'hui on dit Facebook ça vaut ça
mais demain il vaudra ça et après demain
il vaudra ça parce que
c'est toujours
en fait c'est vraiment de l'économie
aujourd'hui là c'est vraiment un système
d'information où tu essayes de
comprendre où est la valeur qui produit
de la valeur d'avoir des informations
c'est vraiment un système d'information
et de transfert de l'information c'est
un prix c'est une information et
chaque fluctuation c'est 4 millions de
personnes qui se disent ah non ça vaut
un peu plus ah non ça vaut un peu moins
et comme ça que ça c'est pour ça que les
prix fluctuent sur ces sur les actions
et les trucs comme ça
donc du coup tu peux vendre un truc à
200 millions de d'euros si tu arrives à
persuader de quelqu'un que ça vaut que
ça vaut 200 millions tu vois il y a pas
d'autres règles que ça quoi c'est
vraiment c'est ça ça reste
vrai dans tous les tous les cas de
figure
convaincre mentir c'est très important
pour devenir riche quoi
moi je vois pas spécialement d'autres
questions dans le chat je pense qu'on va
s'arrêter là déjà ça a duré bien plus
longtemps que prévu
en fait
dit que ce serait plus court ouais mais
on va commencer plus tard ouais mais tu
vois je regarde le temps là c'est un peu
dans les clous de ouais mais en fait
c'est juste que sur la session de test
en gros ça m'a duré 2 heures au lieu de
2h30 j'ai rajouté toute la phase avec
Lucie dans le laboratoire Souter
beaucoup de discussions derrière ah oui
c'est à dire qu'à la base il y a lucide
pas venir enfin non en fait ce
laboratoire souterrain de base il était
ami réa
et vous y n'était pas allé dans
l'épisode d'avant ah ouais d'accord
c'est là tu vois au début
on aurait dû suivre la piste de la
raffinerie ou je sais pas quoi
là c'est un autre truc qui était pas
loin de le village aussi sauf que du
coup vu qu'il fallait qu'on boucle en
moins d'épisode que prévu je l'avais mis
de côté
le moine tibétain ok tu vois donc
qui vit en communion avec la nature et
tout très zen etc et qui du coup eux ont
appris à vivre sans le spolio ah oui
sans le spoil est-ce qu'ils font des
colocations avec les du coup
sabots là
ils auraient été aveuglés par nos
torches
non mais pas
votre avis
avec l'expo évidemment depuis que les
savants je m'étais dit ce serait cool de
un incendie mais même où là
depuis l'Occitanie
juste pour parler de ça parce que je me
suis dit c'est vrai que c'est dur de
combattre un feu alors imaginons
combattre un feu qu'on peut pas voir
comment on fait et eux
comment on fait
en plus on sait pas où il est bon on
s'avance on se brûle et on fait ah c'est
là
et maintenant il faut faire le tour pour
savoir jusqu'où ça va
aller sur ce
non là bon on va on va clôturer ici donc
merci d'avoir suivi ces quatre épisodes
de tes Brest de spolium c'était super
cool on a vraiment passé un bon moment
on est un peu triste que ça dure pas 8
épisodes mais bon c'est comme ça
toujours est-il que les quatre épisodes
qu'on a fait nous on est super fiers et
on est très content de ce qu'on a réussi
à faire moi je suis très content de
l'histoire que j'ai réussi à amener et
je suis très content de où les joueurs
ont réussi à amener tout ça parce que
quand même c'était quand même très cool
vous avez eu des bonnes idées l'heure de
rien vous vous rendez pas compte mais
vous avez beaucoup créé des choses
indirectement notamment le fait que les
Aigles rouges soient méchants c'était
pas prévu à la base
les rouges
euh moi je sens je suis autoritarisme là
je m'étais dit c'est des gens un peu
un peu bourruu quoi non un peu stricte
quand même oui mais qui veulent le bien
ouais
vous l'avez pris plutôt
mal du coup c'est forcément mauvais
sieste et du coup je me suis dit ok ben
je vais partir
c'est le début
rouge qui veulent détruire ici à partir
de où il y a plein de choses comme ça
des petites idées que vous avez lâché je
me suis dit ok je vais partir là-dessus
vous en êtes pas rendu compte que vous
avez en partie écrit l'histoire quand
même
des trucs à côté desquels on est passé
aussi
des trucs que j'ai pas eu le temps
d'écrire du coup je me suis voilà
on n'a pas grimpé la montagne c'est
dommage mais bon la montagne
bon du coup merci d'avoir suivi on
remercie toutes les équipes qui ont
permis que tout ça ce soit faisable on
remercie aussi le le CNC qui est quand
même qui nous aide à financer ok on
remercie Marie est escalier Laurent
codoul Renan lazul désolé si j'écorche
les noms on me les a donné une fois je
les ai juste noté donc il faut je
prononce mal désolé à vous si jamais
vous voyez ça merci quand même
Jean Carbonnel Nicolas papillon et
Daniel arquier à la Régie Nicolas Bono
Hugo boustament et l'immeison Agathe
Delplace et Clément Morineau et
évidemment les quatre joueurs autour de
la table qu'on ne présente plus donc
n'hésitez pas allez voir oui c'est bon
allez voir ce qu'ils vont sur leur
chaîne il y a les commandes dans le chat
point d'exclamation de Willow je fais
des lives des fois sur twitch
donc on se retrouve dans pas si
longtemps dans un peu plus d'un mois sur
ta chaîne oui on est un autre projet un
peu marrant attends c'est dans un peu
plus d'un mois dans deux mois on est le
début mais c'est oui c'est le 21
juin
la fête de la musique sur ma chaîne
youtube on fera un petit concert
scientifique
le son qu'est-ce qu'une onde sonore
finalement non mais voilà on va faire un
petit concert ça va être sympa
est-ce que on aura aussi un autre truc
qui arrivera un petit peu plus tard au
mois d'août dans l'été mais ça on vous
l'annoncera plus tard avec The Wilou
cher joueuse cher joueur qu'est-ce que
vous allez être prévu vous de beau sur
twitch sur Youtube et bien moi je serai
dans un événement dont j'ai oublié le
nom mais c'est SCOP dans une semaine
d'Arte pour parler de 2050 le futur et
qu'est-ce que ça nous réserve alors là
pour le coup on sera pas dans un rôle on
va on va jouer un JdR ça encore ensemble
l'équipe de choc
parce que le but c'est quand même pour
de vrai cette fois-ci je pense de de pas
cramer le monde ouais on va essayer
ce soir on crame le monde
et l'autre c'est non non en fait c'est
vraiment important
fais attention les petites fleurs non
mais on va justement il y a plein de
scénarios de la dame qui évoque le futur
en 2050 et est-ce qu'on part plutôt sur
de la sobriété ou est-ce que c'est un
contrôle
via les régions nation où est-ce que
c'est des trucs de consortium est-ce que
enfin plein de schémas différents est-ce
que c'est plus l'innovation les Sabri
sobriété et du coup il y a plein de
scénarios comme ça et d'essayer de
parler de ces différentes de ces
différents scénario de ce que ça recoupe
et voilà voilà avec le dernier rapport
du GIEC aussi sur lequel on va revenir
avec plein d'invités ce sera en public à
la gai lyrique dans le coin allez-y
ouais dimanche passionnés
c'est le 14 mai donc le 14 c'est ça oui
avec plein de gens on aura un envoyer
spécial aussi Pierre Girard en direct de
Normandie enfin il y aura tout et c'est
un JdR qui sera animé par fibre optique
si vous avez aimé ce que j'ai écrit
dites-vous que moi je débute dans l'idée
par rapport à fibre et je me suis
beaucoup inspiré de lui de sa façon
d'écrire donc si vous avez apprécié ce
que j'ai écrit vous allez apprécié ce
que fibro fait parce que ce sera juste
mieux voilà donc allez voir ce sera bien
on verra en tout cas un retour
pas mon truc
trop drôle et Clotilde
moi je vous donne rendez-vous le 15 mai
pour la suite de mission archéo donc le
prochain reportage sur fouille arrive le
15 mai voilà et souvent sur twitch aussi
ouais je suis tous les mercredis soir et
mercredi à 19h sur twitch
j'anime avec Lucas pacott qui est mon
compagnon et l'auteur des scripts de la
chaîne on joue à geogester mais version
archéo donc
Street Street View quoi a mis en place
des cartes avec que des sites archéo
donc nous ça nous permet
je sais je commente positivement non
mais c'est cool parce qu'il y a des
Pays-Bas en soit on reconnait facilement
Italie Grèce et puis il y a d'autres
pays où on découvre carrément les
les sites quoi c'est des sites quand
même connus enfin c'est des sites mis en
tourisme
voilà
très bien et très bien bon ça raccroche
et bien il va faire tout noir
c'est la le processus de votre foutu
usine là qui est en train de
[Musique]